den gestrigen tag und den gestrigen
abend zusammen fasst jetzt meine
kollegin kirsten becker von den
tagesthemen draußen tausende die
demonstrieren gegen die die sich drinnen
demonstrativ einig zeigen eine große
jungs dabei war im vorfeld die afg
stimmung eher angespannt nichts schien
unmöglich bei der chef war aufruhr und
ablehnung im saal als der antisemit
gedeon antritt mit drei prozent
zustimmung eine fußnote wollten gewinnt
mit knapp 70 prozent
ich sage es klipp und klar werden müssen
nun regierungswillig und fällt werden
das ist uns aufgetragen
das ist die aufgabe für die nächsten
zwei jahre ähnlich aber noch
selbstbewusster klang das auch beim
bisherigen co chef alexander gerlach und
wenn grüne rote und dunkelrote
zusammengehen wird der tag kommen an dem
eine geschwächte cdu nur noch eine
option hat uns als bundessprecher löst
ihn nun sein wunschkandidat
ich schlage vor den nachfolger von mir
kino kompalla vor
trotz dieser rückendeckung auch per
handzeichen gewinnt die sächsische
bundestagsabgeordnete und malermeister
erste bild stichwahl
er gibt sich moderat nur mit
überzeugenden inhalten werden wir neue
wählerschichten erschließen dazu braucht
ist keine drastische sprache und mit
drastischer sprache
drückt man häufig das gegenteil vor
allem bei den frauen unterstützung für
coop als bewerbungen kam allerdings auch
vom flügel um rechtsaußen blöcke aus
dessen landesverband thüringen und
ebenfalls die welt auch er stefan brandt
gerade als vorsitzender des
rechtsausschusses im bundestag abgesetzt
weil ihm die anderen fraktionen aufgrund
umstrittener äußerungen die menschliche
und politische eigenen für das amt
absprechen nun ist er stellvertretender
vorsitzender der 8
ja wir sehen hier noch einen blick in
die halle hier in braunschweig wo in den
nächsten minuten der parteitag eröffnet
wird knapp 600 delegierte wählen wie
gesagt den rest des bundesvorstandes die
sogenannten beisitzer noch ja und bei
mir hier am set steht einer der schon
gewählt ist nämlich der neue
bundessprecher ist gleich
parteivorsitzender tino keller sind
quasi der nachfolger der in die
fußstapfen von alexander gauland tritt
sie sind gestern die stichwahl gegangen
gegen gottfried curio das war ja auch zu
erwarten sie haben gewonnen mit 54
prozent auch das war zu erwarten
54 prozent ist fast genau der gleiche
wert denn gestern ihre sozusagen
vorsitzenden kollegen von der spd
novarro und saskia esken der spd bei
einem bieten der entscheid gewonnen oder
hallo errungen haben 54 prozent können
sie damit gut leben mit dieser
zustimmung ja doch ich kann damit sehr
gut leben es war ja im prinzip eine
spannende war es war eine stichwahl und
gottfried krüger ist ja auch ein sehr
guter gegenkandidat gewesen muss man
sagen ist ein ambitionierter guter
redner bei uns in der bundestagsfraktion
von daher bin ich sehr zufrieden
früher war sie also dass viele
delegierte die ja hier die basis
vertreten
karin bock auf das hatten was die
parteiführung eigentlich wollte jetzt
sind sie dem vorschlag der das
parteiestablishment gefolgt nämlich sie
zum ko vorsitzenden zu wählen ist das so
eine art normalisierung die man da merkt
bei der afd
ich denke ja es ist eine
professionalisierung mittlerweile werden
erwachsen das kann man schon so sagen
nach sechs jahren merkt man dass unsere
parteitage auch konzentrierter
stattfinden durchlaufen und das erkennt
man dass wir in der weise immer mehr bei
professionalisierte auch auftreten es
gibt es ja in jeder partei so auch bei
der afg so trendlinien oder
unterschiedliche interessen
unterschiedliche strukturen ich nenne
jetzt mal zwei in der afg osten westen
und sich als gemäßigt bezeichnet oder
bürgerlich und der so genannte flügel
sie haben ja gestern angekündigt so als
was sie ihr programm die zusammen zu
führen muss man sich das vorstellen denn
da gibt es ja auch ganz unterschiedliche
auffassungen da gibt es möglicherweise
auch viele persönlichen differenzen
da haben sie ja eigentlich auch eine
menge zu tun sieht man ja auch an den
wahlergebnissen zum gestern auf alle
fälle eine persönliche animositäten gibt
es natürlich in allen parteien man sieht
es ja irgendwie einer spd natürlich auch
bei uns wir haben aber gestern anhand
dieser doppelspitze zeigen können dass
im prinzip auch beide lager auch ost und
west gleichermaßen repräsentierten 8
gerade nach den guten wahlergebnissen
osten also dass vertrieb partei eher
zusammenführen und ich bin da sehr
zuversichtlich
sie haben ja gestern noch darauf
hingewiesen es ganz gut wenn die partei
von einem akademiker und von einem nicht
akademiker als professor x und tina
klopp aller malermeister aus görlitz
geführt wird
war das jetzt nötig zu sagen dass sich
da alle auch irgendwie von der kfd also
den mitgliedern den wählern da irgendwie
mit integriert fühlen
auf alle fälle ich denke wir müssen auch
unsere unsere wähler repräsentieren
ich bin die starke stimme nicht nur des
ostens natürlich auch der der handwerker
und der mittelständer für die ich im
bundestag politik mache das ist die
mittelschicht wo wir immer mehr sehen
dass die mittelschicht erodiert dass die
mittelschicht eigentlich politisch kaum
noch von einer partei vertreten wird und
das will ich in der afg tun und ich
denke dass ich damit mit dieser wahl
auch das repräsentieren kann
jetzt gelten sie ja wie auch der
co-vorsitzende wir haben jetzt gerade ja
schon ein bisschen angesprochen mit dem
stichwort mittelschicht so als
wirtschaftsliberal es gibt aber hier
auch ein sozial für die manche sagen
sogar er sei sozial populistisch den zum
beispiel birnböck repräsentiert da gibt
es ja demnächst möglicherweise auch
ärger bei der frage wie das
rentenkonzept der asd aussieht wie
nehmen sie die dann mit die diese
meinung die sie vertreten gerade wenn
wirtschaftsliberalen fragen dann nicht
so sehr teilen gut also wir haben ja
verschiedene rentenkonzept sie haben es
angesprochen
von wegen hacker offenen professor
mountain ich halte habe am bein noch
eine gewisse kritikpunkte ist muss ich
auch sagen
wenngleich ich werde mir dass das
wirtschaftliche in dieser partei
bestärken dass soziale automatisch mit
dem auch die rentenfrage und wir werden
das auf dem sozialpartner erklären wir
werden dort konzept zur abstimmung haben
und werden uns auch ein einheitliches
rentenkonzept einigen können und das ist
auch meine aufgabe natürlich dazu
beizutragen dass wir das als
gesamtpartei beschaffen können sie haben
in einem brief an die mitglieder des
kreisverbandes görlitz geschrieben sie
sollen sich vor journalisten in acht
nehmen da könnten auch getan der
zersetzung agenten
darunter seien jetzt bringt ihre neue
funktion als parteivorsitzender mit sich
da sie ziemlich vielen journalisten zu
tun haben werden welchen umgang haben
sie sich da vorgenommen mit journalisten
ich habe grundsätzlich mit journalisten
keine probleme es gibt natürlich wie in
jeder branche auch bei den journalisten
schwarze schafe die sich eben nicht an
die vereinbarung halten die sich auch
nicht an den pressekodex halten das muss
man ganz klar sagen das habe ich
kritisiert dazu habe ich auch meine
mitglieder im einzel mit presse kothe ja
es gibt aber auch bei ihnen im
pressekodex mit gewissen fristen die man
einhalten sollte wenn man fragen an die
abgeordneten zum beispiel oder an den
bundesvorstand stellt die wurden zum
teil nicht eingehalten das meine ich
damit und wir möchten natürlich auch die
die mitglieder sensibilisieren mit
presseanfragen besonnen umzugehen und
vielleicht auch einfach auch mal eine
rückfrage zu stellen bevor man über mal
schnell antwortet und sich dort zur
äußerung hinreißen lässt die im prinzip
die presse auch gezielt gegen uns
verwendet haben in der vergangenheit
immer wieder gesehen könnte ich jetzt
als gegenfrage stellen wäre es für die
afg besser vielleicht etwas gelassener
auch mit journalisten umzugehen grad mit
denen die ihnen vielleicht nicht so
gewogen sind oder sie meinen dass sie
nicht so gewogen
jetzt will ich nichts sagen es gibt
natürlich es gab in der vergangenheit
helmut kohl hat zum beispiel den
spiegeln interview gemacht oder mit
panorama also es gibt in der
vergangenheit repräsentative
persönlichkeiten die das ebenso
gehandhabt haben wenn presseleute sich
nicht eine gewisse absprachen halten
kann man das durchaus tun
das werde ich auch tun schaue man das
genau an und das ist ja mein gutes recht
zu sagen mit denen reden ich toll mit
ihr möchte ich nicht reden
das machen die presseleute im übrigen
genauso gut also
natürlich habt ihr das recht interviews
nicht jedem zu geben die diese nicht
möchten wir trotzdem nach wie vor
versuchen von ihnen antworten auf fragen
zu kriegen
und natürlich auch jeden hier der etwas
zu sagen hat für die afg zu interviewen
zu sagen hatte hier etwas tun okpala der
neue vorsitzende co vorsitzende der kfd
vielen dank dass sie da waren und wir
geben jetzt zu katharina kühn die unten
im saal bei den delegierten steht ja und
hier im saal haben wir zwei menschen
gefunden die mit der presse reden wollen
vielen dank auch dafür martina jost und
matthias lißke weise sind
landtagsabgeordnete frau jost in sachsen
und herrliche in sachsen-anhalt erstmal
herrliche wie zufrieden sind sie denn
mit dem wahlergebnis gestern ja ich bin
sehr zufrieden ich glaube wir haben
gezeigt dass wir professionelle
parteitage durchführen können und ich
bin mit den gewählten vertretern sehr
zufrieden
finden sie denn sagen dass das ein
ausgeglichener bundesvorstand soweit ist
ich denke er ist ausgeglichen und stelle
mit den heutigen wahlen die jetzt noch
anstehen werden einen perfekten
bundesvorstand haben der uns die
nächsten jahre gut führen wird was muss
denn passieren damit dieser
bundesvorstand perfekt wird ich denke es
ist gut wenn man alle strömungen
vertreten haben und ich denke das
genauso passieren also von daher ich
freue mich auf den heutigen tag frau
just es wurde vorher auch immer gesagt
dass gerade die ostdeutschen verbände
mehr repräsentiert werden müssen im
bundesvorstand
bisher ist mit tino kubala eine person
da alle anderen sind dann doch deutlich
für westdeutschland stehen sie würden
sie sagen hat das geklappt jetzt mit
einer person im bundesvorstand reicht
das also wir haben noch eine zweite
person gestern gewählt den
stellvertretenden
schatzmeister der kommt auch aus unserem
landesverband also wir sind sehr
zufrieden dass wir also auch
entsprechend unserer wahlergebnisse dass
wir jetzt einen vorsitzenden platzieren
konnten
und ich glaube das ist sehr ausgewogen
was die beiden vorsitzenden gemeinsam
aus ost und west gezeigt haben dass
extremismus bei uns in der partei keinen
platz hat insofern sind wir aus unserer
sicht der ostdeutschen bundesländer sehr
zufrieden mit dem ergebnis
jetzt wurden auch schon mal die
strömungen angesprochen was würden sie
sagen wir haben gehört dass der flügel
zum beispiel nicht ganz so zufrieden
bisher ist sehen sie dass das ja dass
der flügel bisher nicht ausreichend
berücksichtigt wurde
also gestern wurde ja auch gesagt dass
der propeller sehr gute kontakte und
auch sehr gut kommuniziert mit dem
flügel ich denke alle strömungen sind im
moment sehr zufrieden
also ich denke nicht dass es da irgend
eine diskrepanz gibt und es wären ja
heute noch weitere kandidaten gewählt
und da wird man sehen wer dann zum
schluss alles noch dabei ist sondern
können wir bilanz ziehen
aber das heißt wenn der flügel jetzt
noch nicht so sehr dabei ist wird er
wohl jetzt stärker vertreten sein werden
in den nächsten wahlen die jetzt kommen
das kann ich nicht sagen also es wird
sicher noch überraschungskandidaten
geben das werden wir sehen
und ich denke dass es wichtig ist und
das gestern wirklich alle gezeigt haben
dass diese strömung zusammen gehören und
dass die auch platz bei uns in der
partei haben aber natürlich wie ich
schon sagte extremismus auf gar keinen
fall
extremismus auf gar keinen fall das
würde hier gestern auch gesagt haben sie
das gefühl wenn dann zum beispiel
trotzdem wolfgang gedeon immer noch in
der partei ist dass das funktioniert ja
also gründe
herget und gehört meinen augen nicht in
die partei muss ich ehrlicherweise sagen
und extremismus gehört nicht in der ard
da gibt es andere parteien die das
vielleicht gut finden wir lehnen das
konkret ab und von daher denke ich mal
werden wir auf den konstruktiven
parteitag haben und selbst die wenigen
prozent
die vorhaben hat mich habe mich schon
extrem verwundert die er gehen und
erhalten
martina hughes und matthias lißke vielen
dank dass sie hier mit uns hingekommen
sind nämlich auch hinter die absperrung
weil wir nicht direkt bei den
delegierten filmen durften und damit
gebe ich erst einmal zurück zu meiner
kollegin doris ich begrüße sie heute am
zweiten tag und denke mal dass wir
sofort auf der bühne einsteigen sollten
weil da die wahl des bundesvorstandes
weitergeht und auf der bühne bereit
stehen
diejenigen die gewählt sind und es geht
direkt weiter mit der wahl des
schriftführers das ist ein teil des
bundesvorstandes eine position und vorne
bewirbt sich nicht bewirbt sondern ist
ein vorschlag gekommen und zwar für
joachim kues was derjenige der das amt
bereits schon inne hat also stellt sich
zur wiederwahl
vater von zehn kindern der sich noch mal
für zwei jahre hier zur kandidatur
bereit erklärt hat ich kann ihnen
vielleicht noch während die zahl der
stimmberechtigten für joachim poß
abgezählt werden noch nachreichen
dass die drei stellvertreter die für die
beiden bundessprecher gewählt werden
wurden stefan brandner sind beatrix von
storch und alice light alice weiter
wurde ohne gegenkandidaten
gegenkandidaten gewählt
die wahl des dritten stellvertreters hat
eine kleine geschichte die will ich
ihnen ganz kurz erzählen denn in den
ersten beiden wahlgängen konnte sich der
bisherige nicht durchsetzen mit gegen
den im dritten wahlgang den er ging dann
werd jetzt durch ins rennen und gewann
gegen den flügel mann stefan rotter also
mit dem dritten stellvertreter beatrix
von storch ist der die bundessprecher
und die stellvertreter komplettiert
worden darunter finden sich zwei frauen
bei den stellvertretern und einen mann
und jetzt geht es eben um die vorschläge
zur wahl des schriftführers hatte ich
einen rat gesagt noch ein fuß und birgit
beziehen stellen sich zur wahl
und demzufolge als zweites ich bitte
herrn zu uns aufstieg
da ist der cruze angekommen meine damen
und herren statt sie bieten deutlich
mehr ruhe einkehren zu lassen
insbesondere auf der tribüne das ist mir
noch entschieden zu laut das wäre
hilfreich wenn sie den parteitag nicht
stört wir fangen bei den richtigen wagen
jetzt sehen sie unter um eine aktuelle
polizeiliche führungszeugnis eintragung
im team
nein keine einfache und geben sie mit
der auskunft über frühere möglichkeit
meine erste partei gut vielen dank fünf
minuten vorstellung des zeitwertes liebe
parteifreunde
guten morgen normalerweise beginne ich
ja solche läden immer mit dem hinweis
auf gewisse dinge die mich nichts dafür
kann aber die themen mode interessiert
heute morgen möchte ich das nicht tun
denn heute geht es ja um das amt des
schriftführers eine der zwei hinter die
in besonderer weise im hintergrund des
bundesvorstandes applaus stattfinden
gestern hat schon hermann ihnen
berichtet über die arbeit die im
bundesvorstand hier zu treffen sind
da bekommen sie in der regel nicht mit
wie viele stunden er damit verbringt und
bei mir ist es ähnlich ich habe als sie
mir von zwei jahren der vertrauen
geschenkt haben
und mehr verantwortung des bundes
übertragen haben
da wusste ich nicht was auf mich zukommt
und die aufgaben die sich da ergeben
haben die habe ich dann erstmal langsam
kennen gelernt und sind im wesentlichen
drei aufgaben die ich bekommen habe und
die sind viele sagen endlich mit leben
kann auch herrmann hat das erste ist der
schriften musste ich um die protokolle
kümmern um die erstellung der protokolle
aber auch um das volk dann damit die
entsprechenden beschlüsse auch vollzogen
werden umgesetzt werden und da das hat
sehr viel sehr viel mitarbeiterbindung
und ich möchte an dieser stelle ganz
besonderen malkursen danken dafür dass
er mir sehr leicht gemacht hat dieser
arbeit dass er mir zu gearbeitet hat und
dass ich hier immer hervorragende
vorlagen bekommen haben und den
korrektur arbeit war immer sehr gering
herzlichen dank die beantwortung
[Applaus]
die zweite aufgabe ist den
mitgliederverwaltung und den gestern
auch hervor mal gesprochen hat nachdem
steffen könige ausgeschieden ist habe
ich diesen teil übernommen der den er
gemacht hat wir haben uns das aufgeteilt
die hälfte der mitglieder prüfung und
aufnahmeprüfungen von denen sie gestern
gehört haben circa 400 bis 600 im monat
müssen wir dann prüfen wir googeln da
die leute schauen um irgendwelche
unvereinbarkeiten stattfinden oder
vorlegen und wir schauen ob auch die
formalen dinge in ordnung sind jeden
monat für mich sogar zwei- bis
dreihundert je nachdem welche prüfungen
sonntagabend ist in dieser arbeit
gewidmet
es hat das mühsam aber es macht spaß vor
allem weil man einen briten kommt
ungefähr über die leute die in die
partei eintreten und das nächste schon
sehr interessant
diesen überblick zu haben und ich würde
diese arbeit auch gern weitermachen
die dritte aufgabe
[Applaus]
sigrid aufgabe die nicht hergibt die
habe ich sozusagen hier mitgemacht
ich habe hier acht aufnahmeanträge und
so genannten ausland mitgliedern
viele wissen gar nicht dass wir ungefähr
dass über 200 mitglieder im ausland
haben die kein stimmrecht haben hier bei
uns weil sie keinen preis sind aber die
müssen genauso wie alle anderen
behandelt werden indem man sie
ansprechen prüfen indem man mit ihnen
das aufnahmegespräch unter anwesenden
führt so steht es in der satzung
und wenn jemand halten dürfen
philippinen wohnt oder in thailand wie
wir haben ist ein bisschen schwierig ich
fahre da nicht hin aber die kommen meist
hierher aber dann trifft man sich halt
irgendwo in frankfurt am flughafen oder
um die schweiz treffe ich in basel am
bahnhof oder von und ich habe vier
wochen habe ich gespräche geführt
jetzt sind acht neue anträge liegen vor
die konnte ich nicht mehr machen weil
ich weiß nämlich noch gewählt werden
insofern muss ich jetzt meinen eventuell
meinem nachfolger übergeben
wenn sie mich hören dann übernehmen
diese aufgabe gerne wieder fit werden
wieder schön
[Applaus]
wir haben hier die verantwortung
übertragen da mal ich weiß was das
bedeutet
und ich bin gerne bereit diese aufgabe
weiter zunehmen den karren sozusagen
weiterzuziehen die maschinenbauer der af
den und deshalb bitte ich um ja schon
rauen und dankte ihnen für die
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
es gibt fragen aussuchen
ja diese wahl verspricht ein wenig
spannend zu werden weil wir auch im kurs
zu den gemäßigteren in der afg fraktion
gehört und er tritt ja an gegen birgit
bessin die eine ausgewiesene flügelfrau
ist sie gehörte zu den
erstunterzeichnern der berühmten
erfurter resolution hoch gehalten waren
das jetzt mitgliedsanträge rinnen und
weil wenn man jetzt standbild macht und
sich die adresse aussuchen
[Musik]
ich denke nicht dass wir hier gesehen
haben aber insofern glaube ich nichts
das ist handschriftlich ausgefüllten
anträge
ich glaube nicht dass sich da etwas
gesehen haben insofern ja gut aber ich
wollte antwort ich ganz bewusst in diese
anträgen mitbringen damit sind neben
ebenbilder nachfolger weiß was auf ihn
zukommt
ich bin aus dem landesverband baden
württemberg
wenn ich dann halt die frage
wir haben den morgen geforscht die haben
die frau doktor weil die vorstand und
die situation in baden württemberg ist
schwierigen momentan also ich habe jetzt
wieder zwei leute in der
landtagsfraktion verloren
unser landesvorstand ist ein bisschen
nicht so schön kommt die frage welchen
anspruch haben hier als landesverband so
vielen neuen in den bundesbahnen zu
senden wenn wir die kunden leute dabei
wurden geschädigt den redezeiten auch
und ihr habt vielen dank für die frage
herr ma tisch ich dachte immer und die
apotheken keine quoten und insofern
spielt das unglaublich keine rolle
[Applaus]
vielen dank
der kustos waren die beiden fragen
fehlen dann für ihre vorstellung und
dann bitte ich als nächstes mit benzin
zu uns auf die bühne ja berge pessin ist
derzeit landtagsabgeordneter in
brandenburg und das seit dem jahr 2014
und 2016 ist sie stellvertretende
landesvorsitzende ebenfalls der afg in
brandenburg geboren in worms so da ist
horst ihnen angekommen vor bisschen auch
an sie zunächst die pflicht fragen würde
ein aktuelles polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragung enthalten
nein das führungszeugnis würde keine
eintragungen enthalten und geben sie
bitte auskunft zur früheren
parteizugehörigkeiten die gibt es nicht
die alternative für deutschland ist
meine erste partei in der ich mitglied
bin
vielen dank dann fünf minuten für die
vorstellung bitte sehr guten morgen
meine sehr geehrten parteikollegen
liebes präsidium liebe gäste
mein name ist christin ich bin 41 jahre
alt glücklich verheiratet und habe ein
zauberhaftes hawks ich bin seit 2013 im
april mitglied der alternative für
deutschland bin in brandenburg
stellvertretende
landesvorsitzende und in unserer
landtagsfraktion stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
ich nehme seit längerem sei den ich
mitglied des landesvorstandes bin an dem
bundesvorstands laden des vorstands der
telefonkonferenzen teil an den
klausurtagungen heißt also ich weiss
kennt die sachverhalte um die es geht
ich beherrsche die deutsche sprache in
wort und schrift und kann damit also
protokolle schreiben
und der kurs hat gerade eindrucksvoll
erklärt welche aufgaben auf einen
schriftführer in diesem bundesvorstand
zukommen würden
und ja ich traue mir diese aufgaben zu
und ja ich habe auch zeit diese aufgaben
zu erledigen
ich kann die ganzen anträge formulieren
ich brauche keinen text korrektur
programm um meine rechtschreibung herr
werden zu können das schaffe ich alleine
dank einer guten bildung die heutzutage
leider nicht mehr jeder in deutschland
genießen kann
die berliner kennen mich als
versammlungsleiter aus vielen ihrer
eigenen landesparteitage und auch in
oberbayern hatte ich die gelegenheit und
durfte dort die versammlung leiten bei
der ausstellung ihrer liste ich finde
tierschutzverein ich liebe musik
die regelmäßig zu konzerten auch dafür
habe ich zeit neben meiner arbeit und
selbstverständlich praktischen
adventszeit auch kekse mit meiner
tochter
dennoch diese zeit bleibt mir dank eines
guten zeitmanagement und ich möchte an
dieser stelle danke sagen
ihr wisst wie haben ich möchte kurz
zurückblicken wir hatten drei echt
klasse wahlkämpfe in brandenburg sachsen
und thüringen und ich möchte an der
stelle danke sagen dank an alle die von
euch uns in diesen drei bundesländern
unterstützt haben die uns geholfen haben
zu diesen siegen
das sind unsere gemeinsamen siege
wir sind in diesen wochen zusammen
gerückt und das ist es was unsere
alternative für deutschland ausmacht
miteinander für die sache nicht
gegeneinander intern wir gewinnen nur
wenn wir zusammenstehen zusammenhalten
wollen wir gemeinsam schleim gemeinsam
plakatieren und wir halten gemeinsam den
kopf dafür hin dass endlich ein
politischer wechsel in unserem land
einzug hält und genau das erwarte ich
auch vor dem zukünftigen neuen und
bislang tollen bundesvorstand das auch
weiter mit super tollen leuten
aufgefüllt wird und wir gemeinsam dieses
land dahin führen wo es hingehört um
einen wechsel um 180 grad so und während
frau beziehen sich den fragen stellt der
delegierten hat alexander keller den
ehemaligen bundessprecher alexander
gauland ja da ist bei uns alles über
gauland zum interviewer land gestern das
war so eine art vermächtnis rede wie sie
gehalten haben für die partei als
scheidender parteivorsitzender lang so
ein bisschen als seien sie auch eine art
bewährungshelfer für ihre ex partei die
cdu glauben sie denn an ein bündnis mit
der cdu in absehbarer zeit von
absehbarer zeit kann ich geredet sein
dafür gibt es jetzt immer noch zu viel
in der cdu die das sich gar nicht
vorstellen können aber ich frage mich
wenn was kommen wird links spd und grüne
zusammen gehen dann hat die eu keine
option mehr
wenn sie die macht nicht endgültig
verlieren will muss sie für eine
bürgerliche mehrheit antreten nur daran
habe ich erinnert ihr favorit timo grub
aller ist gestern gewählt worden als ihr
nachfolger
wenn sie sich die ganze wahl gestern die
beiden vorsitzenden die stellvertreter
ansehen sind sie zufrieden mit dem wie
der parteitag gewählt hat ja ich bin
sehr zufrieden das ist auch ausgewogen
jetzt was die flügel die
positionierungen der afg angeht das ist
eine ausgewogen vor allen dingen können
sie das musikland geschrieben und ich
groß geschrieben nicht sagen dass die
partei nach rechts gerückt ist
das heißt es zeigt sich dass qualität
sich durchsetzt und das ist gestern
geschehen und das finde ich sehr gut
der flügel das hat man gehört jetzt
gestern abend hatte morgens aber
unzufrieden mit dem wie das abgelaufen
ist werden die jetzt entschädigt
kompensiert bei der weise den beisitzern
das weiß ich nicht aber flügel
unzufrieden ist das müssen sie die
flügel vertreter fragen und
entschädigung das gibt es in bad nauheim
auf dem parteitag nicht
es setzten sich die leute durch von
denen die partei das gefühl hat dass sie
gut sind und einen beitrag leisten
können da gibt es keine entschädigung
sie können auch nicht jemanden
entgegensetzen der vielleicht nicht gut
ist und dann wird er gewählt als
entschädigung das geht nicht
nach den ereignissen gestern bei der spd
könnten ja neuwahlen dem nichts
passieren ist die aida gut vorbereitet
und werden sie sich auch im
bundestagswahl entsprechend einsetzen
ich werde mich natürlich in der
bundestagsverwaltung entsprechend
einsetzen und vorbereitet sind wir auch
aber so recht glaube ich noch nicht an
die neuwahlen weil ich mich weil ich
nicht weiß wen die spd dann als
spitzenkandidat aufstellen will das neue
duo kennt ja niemand von daher sehe ich
das noch mit gewisser gelassenheit sind
denn die neuen parteivorsitzenden auch
die spitzenkandidaten für die
bundestagswahl
das weiß ich nicht bei der er als die
absolut bei der afd
das weiß ich nicht das wird die partei
bestimmen das kann ich ihnen heute nicht
sagen
gut das werden wir abwarten alexander
gauland hier im interview bei phoenix
herzlichen dank dass sie dabei und wir
geben zu dass mitarbeiter ja vielen dank
wir haben die worte von alexander
gauland in höhe der jetzt natürlich
schnell wieder runter in den saal muss
und natürlich die wahlen weiteren
bundesvorstandsmitglieder mit
begleitenden mit
stunden zu können wir sind in der
fragerunde immer noch bei kb ziehen und
kann nur sagen welche fragen will kann
bis hin zu beantworten muss aber ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen es ist nicht
meine eigene leistung das ist die
leistung von ganz vielen menschen die
zusammen gearbeitet haben die zusammen
gestanden haben einer alleine schafft so
was nicht nur als mannschaft in einem
großen team sind wir gut in dem wir
zusammenstehen
vielen dank frau bisschen vielen dank
für ihre vorstellung und meine damen und
herren wir kommen dann jetzt auch ist
natürlich will sie bitte die stimmzettel
nicht raus wenn die stimmen geräte und
an die tür bitte ich dann die tür zu
schließen wenn niemand mehr vor der tür
steht
[Musik]
wir stehen ja so die beiden kandidaten
wobei man schon sagen kann so besteht
eine erstmal einstimmigen ja dann und
sich mit dem sichtbaren war nach sorte
zwischen der ausgewiesenen flügel frau
birgit bessin und dem zehnfachen
familienvater joachim kuss kommt der
dieses amt bereits innehatte er wurde
2017 in dieses amt gewählt und musste
sich ebenfalls fragen um seine funktion
und um seine arbeit beantwortet diese
fragen beantworten
[Musik]
jedes amt wird nach wie vor wie gestern
auch der wahlgang sich gerade von der
versammlungsleiter christoph basedow
gehört haben ist jetzt eröffnet wie
gesagt alles genau so wie bei den wahlen
zu den bundes sprechern und den
stellvertretern es dauert ungefähr eine
minute
die delegierten können nach wie vor
elektronisch abstimmen weil dieses
abstimmungsprozedere am schnellsten
voran geht weil das alles elektronisch
über einen software programm läuft in
dem die ergebnisse und manchmal
funktioniert die elektronik nicht
einige stimmen geräte funktionieren
nicht tücken der technik
der akku leer sein sollte gucken sie mal
aufs gerät das wird er angezeigt
herr basedow saft gerade das ist einige
geräte gibt die offensichtlich akku
probleme haben das ist natürlich unser
weise für eine wahl nicht gut
also neueröffnung eine minute
delegierten jetzt abstimmen
die einen brauchen länger die anderen
haben ihre wahl direkt getroffen und so
die spannend wird jetzt sein inwieweit
gegebenenfalls den amtierenden bundes
führen wird oder ob das weitermachen
was ist hier los
so wie rechne wahlgang noch mal ab wir
haben noch ein stimmgerät das nicht geht
machen wir die tür noch mal auf
ja jetzt wird der wahlgang noch mal
abgebrochen das gibt mir vielleicht die
gelegenheit ihnen ganz kurz zu erzählen
wie der tag heute weiter verlaufen wird
denn diese wahlen sind ja noch lange
nicht beendet nachdem schriftführer gibt
es einen stellvertretenden schriftführer
der bereits gewählt wurde gestern das
ist ein netz ist mir der name grad
entfallen meine kollegin wird ihn aber
gleich nachreichen
und dieser mann ist gestern ich weiß
dass es ein hannes der ist gestern
gewählt worden
und dann gibt es noch die vier beisitzer
die ebenfalls gewählt werden alles
weiter und beatrix von storch die ja bis
dato beisitzerinnen sind ja aufgerückt
in der stellvertreterriege und diese
wahlen werden dann beendet danach wird
es noch die wahl des ehrenvorsitzenden
geben
da stellt sich alexander gauland zur
wahl um das amt dieses ehrenvorsitzende
des neu geschaffenen ehrenvorsitzenden
zu bekleiden
und nach diesen wahlen wird es dann noch
satzungs anträge das was alexander
gauland gestern als graubrot bezeichnet
hat wird es auch noch geben denn die
restlichen satzungs anträge und die
anträge zur finanz und beitragsordnung
müssen noch behandelt werden
und es gibt ja auch noch zwei sache
anträge die der parteitag bescheiden
muss und zwar einmal die resolution zur
nutzung der kernkraft in dem es darum
geht dass der energieträger kernkraft
für die afd
ein teil des energiekonsums ausmachen
soll weiterhin und die frage wie die
partei mit dem ehemaligen alpha leuten
umgeht um den ehemaligen hp chef lukas
gibt es das ergebnis für die
schriftführer war
das ergebnis bitter einblenden
ja die elektronik macht das der afc in
diesem moment spannend denn ich glaube
der ganze saal wartet auf dieses
ergebnis des schriftführers ich meine
mich zu erinnern dass sie auch im kurs
bei seiner ersten wahl damals keinen
gegenkandidaten hatte es aber bitte
keine gesicherte information
jedenfalls hat er in diesem fall bei
dieser wiederwahl eine gegenkandidatin
tücken der technik trifft alle auch ein
parteitag wie diesen in dem das
elektronische wahlverfahren ja
durchgängig genutzt werden soll und eben
wie in diesem falle ein bisschen
ruckelig es gehört
wir stellen fest für frau werden 265
stimmen kuss 161 9 stimmen für ein und
sechs enthaltungen damit hatte niemand
die einfache mehrheit erreicht und wir
kommen in eine stichwahl zwischen
denselben kandidaten die tür bitte
einmal auf ja kein ergebnis
keiner hat erforderliche mehrheit
erfüllt erster wahlgang für den
schriftführer
was bedeutet dass weitere kann
vielleicht katharina kühn im saal
erörtern
ja und neben mir steht jetzt burkhard
schröder der tatsächlich auch seinen
abstimmungs gerät hiermit zum interview
genommen hat erstmal vielen dank dass
sie hier sind obwohl sie gleichzeitig
noch wählen was würden sie denn erwarten
was muss bei diesen wahlen passieren
damit doch diese zerrissenheit in der
partei zwischen flügel und so genannten
gemäßigten er zusammen fließen kann
also ich denke dass bis jetzt sehr gute
ausgewogenheit von vielen anderen
mitgliedern sehr harmonisch verlaufen
ist
darüber freue ich mich zunächst mal und
das extrem forderungen zum beispiel
keine mehrheit gefunden haben
insbesondere freut mich extrem darüber
dass auch gestern gedeon und so war ich
auch mit ein initiator ob dem aufstehen
und sofort ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
noch mehr leute den saal verlassen
hätten weil antisemitismus hat den hfg
also auch keinen platz und der sollte
einfach mal die partei verlassen
ja sie sagen die antisemitismus hat in
der partei keinen platz andererseits hat
man es nicht geschafft ihn vom platz zu
verweisen bisher und das geht seit
jahren das natürlich das parteienrecht
also das ist natürlich den parteien sehr
schwer macht parteiausschlussverfahren
obwohl durchzusetzen
sehr sehr schwierig geworden sind ja
sehr hoch und wir versuchen das
allerdings
er ist auch in der folge fraktion
ausgeschlossen worden
und die spd hat genau so probleme
irgendwo sarrazin loszuwerden nicht das
ist einfach es ist halt nicht so einfach
warum fühlt sich dann so jemand wie
wolfgang kilian anscheinend in der afc
wohl versuchen natürlich wird man sagen
da einfluss zu nehmen er ist ist
natürlich eine gestalt ja mit mit einem
guten charakter und diese leute die
finden einander parteien genauso und er
muss halt einfach insgesamt ausgegrenzt
werden das haben auch gestern besuch und
jetzt das ergebnis also nur 22 stimmen
bekommen hat meines erachtens noch immer
zu viel
ja ist schon mal ein zeichen dafür dass
so etwas und antisemitismus in unserer
partei keinen platz hat sie sich heute
vom parteitag wenn sie sagen
antisemitismus hat zb keinen platz hieß
es mit radikalen meinungen ich denke da
zum beispiel an die identität
was erwarten sie vom heutigen parteitag
das also auch die übrigen plätze so
besetzt werden muss mit gemäßigten
flüchtigen menschen ja die wir in
unseren reihen in der hauptsache haben
und ich denke wir kriegen also sehr gut
bundesvorstand bekommen hier ist hier
gewählt wie eine gute dinge haben durch
die reihen der delegierten geht und die
einzelgespräche geführt bin ich da sehr
zuversichtlich
burkhard schröder herzlichen dank dass
sie sich die zeit genommen haben und wir
wollen wieder nach vorne schauen mit
meiner kollegin doris ja vielen dank
katharina kühn und der delegierte muss
jetzt ein drittes mal abstimmen denn im
zweiten wahlgang war genau das gleiche
ergebnis für die beiden kandidaten für
die wahl eines stadtführers wie im
ersten wahlgang keiner der beiden hat
die erforderliche mehrheit erhalten
die delegierten haben jetzt den wahlgang
noch mal neu eröffnet das heißt es gibt
noch einmal neue vorschläge
die neueröffnung ist komplett auf reset
gedrückt
und jetzt werden noch mal vorschläge für
die wahl des schriftführers genannt es
können jetzt noch neue namen auftreten
bisher sind die beiden die bisher auch
sich zur wahl gestellt haben auf dieser
liste keine neuen kandidaten es ist aber
eine neueröffnung des wahlganges bisher
sind setzte auf die alten kandidaten
wieder auf der liste und ich kann ihnen
noch nachreichen dass carsten hüter der
mann ist der neue stellvertretende
schriftführer der stellvertretend
bundesschatzmeister der afg begonnen sie
stammt aus sachsen beschlossen und
stelle ebenso fest dass durch beide
vorgeschlagen haben frau beziehen stehen
sie zur wahl bereit
ja und fuß stehen sie zur wahl bereit ja
auch beide stehen bereit
beide haben sich vorgestellt wir können
also in die wahl des schriftführers
unmittelbar eintreten so das ist jetzt
formal zwar eine neue wahl aber es gibt
keine neuen kandidaten das heißt die
beiden bisherigen kandidaten birgit
beziehen und es stellen sich auch in der
neueröffnung mit in der einzelwahl zum
schriftführer
das kann man als ersten offenen
machtkampf zwischen den beiden
strömungen vielleicht so werden weil
beide keine mehrheit in den ersten
beiden davor gegangenen wahlgängen
bekommen haben hat beide ungefähr um die
50% es wird jetzt also spannend ob beim
dritten wahlgang der kein dritter
wahlgang ist sondern ein neu eröffneter
wahlgang also ein erster wahlgang in der
neueröffnung aber mit den bisherigen
kandidaten ob es dort jemanden gibt der
dann eine mehrheit hat die wäre meine
vermutung allerdings sehr knapp weil die
beiden bisherigen ergebnisse auch knapp
ausgegangen sind aber beide haben eben
keine erforderliche mehrheit bekommen
eine einfache mehrheit
jetzt müssen wir noch warten auf die auf
das ende des wahlganges alles scheint
offensichtlich jetzt zu klappen jedes
stimmgerät hat genug akku und in wenigen
sekunden können wir die ergebnisse oder
das ergebnis sehen ja damit hat die auf
dem fuß
knapp die mehrheit erreicht
nein stimmen und drei enthaltungen damit
hat der kurs die erforderliche einfache
mehrheit der stimmen erreicht und ist
zum schriftführer gewählt herr cruise
nehmen sie diese wahl an
er nimmt die wahl an 279 stimmen für die
einfache mehrheit
er hat genau diese einfache mehrheit
erreicht mit 50 18 stimmen geflügel und
landtagsabgeordnete aus brandenburg
berlin ist also knapp unterlegen so
jetzt geht es weiter mit den wahl der
beisitzer sind insgesamt 4
und jetzt gibt es vorschläge für diesen
wahlgang gültiger vorschlag haben die
mikrofone
gibt es weitere vorschläge rotes micro
hat sich jemand macht bitte schön
ich glaube dass beide ja nimmer unter
streit als person auch gültiger
vorschlag rote trikot
keine weiteren vorschläge dann bitte in
ihrer zustimmung die kandidatenliste
damit zu schließen wir den zustimmt blau
stimmkarte bitte danke schön wärs gegen
die schließung der kandidatenliste so
ich denke da kann man ähnliche strömung
martin reichert gehört flügel nahen
gruppierungen innerhalb der afg-arena
lammert sitzt seit 2009 10 im
europäischen parlament frau linner
sylvia wimmer ich wiederhole noch mal
den namen dr silvia limmer sie stammt
aus bayern und sitzt seit 2009 10 im
europäischen parlament in brüssel
als erster stellt sich vor frau doktor
limmer so kandidatenkür ist eröffnet die
vorstellung fünf minuten und dann auf
die fragen ansehen
und als erster hat die vorstellung die
europa abgeordnete oliver
da ist hier wunderbar frauen immer auch
als ex-minister schlicht fragen würde
ein aktuelles polizeiliches
führungszeugnis einsparungen enthalten
nein es werde keine eintragungen und
geben sie bitte auskunft über frühere
parteizugehörigkeit keine von
parteizugehörigkeiten fielen dann dann
fünf minuten zeit für die vorstellung
bitteschön
schönen guten morgen auch von mir das
noch sagen darf liebe parteifreunde vor
ziemlich genau einem jahr stand ich an
ähnlicher stelle
damals vor den eu delegierten in
magdeburg und zu wenig seit juli dieses
jahres von ehemals listenplatz neun der
eu-liste aus in das politische lassen
sie es mich so formulieren parallelen
universum des eu-parlamentes
katapultiert worden
inzwischen liegen vier für mich äußerst
lehrreiche monate hinter mir sieht man
die vierwöchige sitzungspause ab und
innerhalb unserer afd delegation bin ich
zuständig für die bereiche umwelt
energie gesundheit verbraucherschutz
tierschutz und landwirtschaft und da ist
promovierte diplom biologin und
approbierte tierärztin finde ich also
genau an der passenden stelle
dort erlebe ich tagtäglich welche
verheerenden ökonomischen und auch
sozialen folgen welchen verfall an
rechtsstaatlichkeit politische
inkompetenz gepaart mit ignoranter
ideologie anzurichten in der lage sind
und letzten mittwoch erst eine
europäische kommission gegen unsere
stimmen bestätigt wurden die ein agenda
ist es den derzeit grassierenden öko
wahn noch schneller voranzutreiben
die eine politik betreibt die schul und
leider oft auch fakten und
wissensbereiche junge klima hüpfer
ermutigt und weiter aufstachelt junge
menschen die ideologischen rattenfängern
auf den leim gegangen sind
rattenfänger mit einer ganz eigenen
intention die anders als die jungen
menschen die politische transformation
zu ende denken mit dem menetekel der
apokalypse und dem weltuntergang nimmt
man volle fahrt auf in einen längst tot
geglaubten sozialismus
ich erlebe ich erlebe eine ich muss sich
unterbrechen ich habe nur fünf minuten
ich erlebe eine ideologisierte politik
die weitab von vernünftigen und von
sachlichen diskussionen grob fahrlässig
als deren willfährige helfer agiert wenn
zb der klima notstand ausgerufen wird so
geschehen am donnerstag ein notstand der
befürchtungen zulässt dass in zukunft
unsere demokratischen grundprinzipien
weiter ausgehebelt werden könnten
lieben parteifreunde
wir sind nun zwar in allen
länderparlamenten vertreten
aber das ausmaß an diffamierungen gegen
unser afd mitglieder ist eines oder ist
er eines totalitären überwachungsstaates
würdig als einer demokratischen
rechtsordnung klar die die überbringer
der schlechten nachricht sind nie gern
gesehene gäste
aber inzwischen sind die medialen
verzerrungen und der billige kampf gegen
alles was irgendwie nach rechts nicht
überhaupt gegen alle kritiker der
grün-linken weltfremden ideen welten
schier unerträglich jede noch so kleine
offene flanke in der ard wird genutzt
und keile zwischen uns zu bleiben um uns
zu schaden
dazu ist nahezu jedes mittel recht
hauptsache es taugt zur stimmungsmache
und in diesen schwierigen zeiten erwarte
ich mir von einem bundesvorstand in
seinem wirken nach innen nach außen zwei
wesentliche dinge zum einen die
organisation und die gestaltung unseres
obergärigen haufens in ein lebendiges
parteien gebildet
dabei darf ruhig in der sache hart
miteinander diskutiert und miteinander
im inhalt gestritten werden muss es
sogar
aber in einer konstruktiven und
sachlichen art des miteinanders für
persönliche angriffe und beleidigungen
darf kein platz sein ist es nämlich das
was wir unseren an unseren politischen
gegner kritisieren und zum anderen
erwarte ich mir von unserem
bundesvorstand ein gezieltes und
gerichtetes wirken nach außen sei es in
der entwicklung von strategien zur
überwindung der beständig zunehmenden
die familie wie auch in der gestaltung
und vermittlung unserer politischen
inhalte dinge klar gehört sicher dazu
aber auch und das mit einigen hier nicht
gefallen
die richtige balance zu finden zwischen
verbaler dauererregung und konstruktiven
lösungsvorschläge
dass wir weit hinter unseren
möglichkeiten liegen erlebe ich täglich
nicht nur meine arbeit in brüssel und
straßburg zum beispiel durch bürger die
mich ansprechen und nichtmitglieder afd
sind aber genug vom vielfältigen
politischen irrsinn haben auch hinter
den kulissen bitten nicht die
unterschiedlichsten verbände der
automobilbranche okay nicht vw sowie
andere industriezweige haben sie zum
schluss und verschiedene deutsche
wirtschaftsverbände politische
unterstützung
und an dieser kommunikation und
strategie entwicklung würde ich gerne
mitwirken wenn sie nicht den lassen da
der geschädigte mit gibt es fragen an
frau dr
die erste frage stellt christian lohse
die zweite frage stellt ja bollinger
die dritte frage stellt kai habicht
ehrlose bitteschön
ja hallo frau limmer im eu-parlament
werden ja auch die co2 zertifikate und
andere dinge behandelt eines der
wichtigsten probleme in der welt
behaupten die klima nutzer brauchen wir
mehr klimaschutz oder brauchen wir mehr
umweltschutz und wofür stehen sie vor
nimmer das kann ich ganz eindeutig
beantworten der die derzeitige politik
des sogenannten klimaschutzes schließt
den umweltschutz geradezu aus das heißt
für mich
ein klima ein klima was sich unstrittige
weise seit jahrmillionen wann wandelt
und daher auch ist der begriff
klimaleugner eigentlich völlig irrsinnig
ja das können wir nicht aufhalten und
auch auf einen bestimmten von uns
festgesetzten stand festfrieren
die umwelt schützen unsere natürlichen
ressourcen jahr das sollte unsere
aufgabe sein
die nächste frage stellte bollinger
bitteschön ja vielen dank frau immer sie
haben eben schon das thema klima politik
und umwelt politik angewiesen ist denn
die klimapolitik wie sie aktuell
umgesetzt wird gut für unsere umwelt
nein vermutlich haben sie mit der
antwort auch gerechnet sie ist nicht gut
aus verschiedenen gründen es ist relativ
verlogen die ganze geschichte
sie haben windräder und erhitzen sie den
schlechten wald ab für die gute
windenergie das ist genau das problem
wenn sie umwelt schützen wollen also die
die umweltschäden verursacht wird zb
durch die erneuerbaren energien sei
selten erden abbau in china sei es die
gebäude der frau baerbock die wir alle
kennen die durch kinderhände arbeit im
kongo aus ihren dunklen höhlen sozusagen
gezogen werden all das sind dinge die
vermeidet man man spricht nicht darüber
verdrängt sie also umweltschutz geht an
das nicht mit erneuerbaren energien
da gibt es noch viel danke schön herr
habe ich stellt die letzte frage bitte
ja habe ich kv kleve wegen und frau
doktor limmer uns war das thema
landwirtschaft ist unter anderem mit dem
thema besteht der neuen bücher vor ort
um die verabschiedet werden soll
und meine frage einerseits die wird ja
voraussichtlich kommen was wäre denn der
richtige weg aus ihrer sicht danke für
diese frage ich habe sehr viel kontakt
auch zu landwirten das hat auch damit zu
tun dass mein eigenes unternehmen
was sich inzwischen vor einigen jahren
abstand veräußert habe in
landwirtschaftliche ausrichtung war
ich komme aus einer ländlichen gegend
und kenne die sorgen und nöte der bauern
das heißt was wir machen müssen alle
erste linie ist dass wir bei der
düngemittelverordnung die die betroffen
sind das heißt die landwirte die das von
ihren vätern ihren großvätern gelernt
haben wo die wissen wo der hammer hängt
und eben nicht technokraten in brüssel
mit an den tisch nimmt und dort wirklich
das tut was not tut
so vielen dank dann sind sie mit dank
und lassen trauma und als nächstes darf
ich dann herren er viele sorten reichen
fragen an volle magie europaabgeordnete
und jetzt kommt martin reichert er ist
bundestagsabgeordneter des geltenden
bundestages gebürtig aus goslar zurück
morgen erreicht hat ich darf sie
zunächst einmal zu den pflicht fragen um
auskunft bitten würde ein polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragungen enthalten
nein danke schön und bitte geben sie an
in welchen parteien sie früher mitglied
waren falls sie das war spd vor 30
jahren ausgetreten republikaner vor
knapp 25 jahren ausgetreten und fdp vor
zehn jahren etwa ausgetreten vielen dank
herr reichert dann haben sie jetzt fünf
minuten 2 um sich und ihr programm
vorzustellen bitteschön liebe
parteifreunde
ich bin martin reichert diplom-pädagoge
verheiratet und habe drei kinder
ich bin landesvorsitzende in
sachsen-anhalt und familienpolitischer
sprecher unserer bundestagsfraktion
ich habe unserem vaterland zwölf jahre
lang als offizier treu gedient
das vereint mich mit euch hier denn auch
ihr hier alle ihr dient treu unserem
vaterland und das ist aller ehren wert
es ist nicht den jämmerlichen empfang
wert der uns und euch den letzten tagen
hier beschert worden ist das was sich da
draußen abgespielt hat das war ein
skandal gegen die demokratie liebe
freunde
da draußen da stehen sie die vaterlands
losen und die feinde der demokratie
sie haben sich dort zusammengefunden die
deutschland hat die unterstützt werden
von den geistigen brandstiftern ralf
stegner
claudia roth und leider gottes auch dem
hässlichen gesicht der deutschen
sozialdemokratie johannes kahrs dessen
gehetze sich im bundestag immer wieder
tragen muss aber den wir dort alle mutig
entgegen halten auf diese
bundestagsfraktion da bin ich stolz
liebe freunde und ich sage euch noch
eins wir lassen uns von diesen leuten
nicht einschüchtern
denn auch was sie immer an lügen und
hetze über uns ausschütten wir wissen
doch wofür wir kämpfen wir wissen wofür
wir politisch stehen wir haben den
politischen kampf aufzunehmen für unsere
familien und für unsere kinder auch
dafür stehe ich im bundestag dafür dass
diesen menschen noch ein leben in einem
deutschland ermöglicht wird dass es noch
wert ist und dass wir alle noch so
nennen können ein deutschland das wir
von unseren vätern ererbt haben liebe
freunde
und hier im saal
das spüren wir doch auch gerade bei den
wahlen und bei der demokratischen
willensbildung die kraft und stärke die
nur dann entsteht weil man ein
gemeinsames ziel hat ein gemeinsames
ziel das wir alle auch in den
wahlkämpfen in sachsen einer in sachsen
und thüringen und in brandenburg
verfolgt haben und diese kraft haben wir
dort gespürt und das hat uns zu einer
hervorragenden ergebnis geführt es war
die einigkeit unserer partei und die
muss das ziel sein auch im künftigen
bundesvorstand liebe freunde und diese
einheit muss das ziel deshalb sein weil
der wähler draußen weil die menschen
draußen eine einige alternative für
deutschland verlangen dürfen und
verdienen
ich selbst habe als mitglied der afc
parteitage erleben müssen auch in meinem
eigenen land die ein unschönes bild
unserer partei geliefert haben jetzt
aber sind unsere parteitage in
sachsen-anhalt getragen von
konstruktiver inhaltlicher arbeit es
sind parteitage die auch der uns nicht
immer wohlgesonnen presse
zähneknirschend respekt abnötigen und
ich denke das ist ein wichtiges ergebnis
und 1 möchte ich sagen die aufgabe eines
bundesvorstands ist es den mitgliedern
und damit auch ihnen und euch allen zu
dienen und ich möchte mich heute hier
mit meiner erfahrung aus sachsen-anhalt
bewerben bei euch als diener für die
einheit und geschlossenheit unserer
partei
das wird mein credo sein für die
kommenden zwei jahre wenn ihr mir das
vertrauen schenkt
die aufgabe des bundesvorstands muss es
sein den konstruktiven geist der partei
zu bündeln denn wir als stärkste
oppositionspartei in deutschland wir
müssen und das ist schon oft gesagt
worden aber es ist essenziell den
zustand des gierigen haufens endlich
überwinden wir müssen weil es die wähler
von uns verlangen sie verlangen von uns
dass wir mittelfristig auch
verantwortung in deutschland übernehmen
und liebe freunde wenn aber ein haufen
zu lange gärt dann besteht die große
gefahr dass es eben auch mittelfristig
mit der übernahme von verantwortung es
sich wird und das haben wir gemeinsam zu
verhindern und dafür will ich antreten
als familienpolitischer sprecher unserer
bundestagsfraktion möchte ich aber auch
die frage der familienpolitik und
gegebenenfalls kampagnen auch im bereich
der verhinderung der kinderrechte ins
grundgesetz und ähnliches in den
bundesvorstand einspeisen
familienpolitik ist essenziell für
unsere heimat den familien und kinder
sind unser aller zukunft sie tragen
deutschland in die zukunft hinein und
das ist ein ganz wichtiges thema das
gerade mir als vater des herzens liegt
stehe ich hier demütig und voller stolz
denn das ist unsere hd das ist unser
deutschland ich bitte um euer vertrauen
vielen dankeschön die vorstellungsrede
des ausgewiesenen flügel mannes martin
reichert
er fraglos die fragesteller aus die
erste frage stellt detlef ehlebracht die
zweite frage stellt thomas rücke man die
dritte frage stellt christian lohse ich
darf also als erstes jahren ehlebracht
am roten mikrofon um seine frage bitten
vielen dank für diese mitreißende rede
ich unterschreibe das wort was sie jetzt
eben gesagt haben allerdings was ich ein
bisschen vermisst und verpasst habe ist
welche aufgabe welches konzept welches
thema nehmen sie sich im bundesvorstand
jetzt persönlich an und bringen es zu
ende
dass wir wegkommen von diesem stigma der
monothematischen parteien
das habe ich deutlich vermisst es waren
allgemein halten die ich wie gesagt alle
mit denen ich mitgehen kann aber ich
habe vermisst was werden sie persönlich
hier und jetzt im vorstand dann anfangen
wenn sie gewählt werden was bringen sie
zu ende
was werden sie als ergebnis bilanz
vorweisen können nach ihrer amtszeit
dankeschön ja vielen dank also was mir
ganz wichtig ist für unsere partei das
ist gerade die frage auch des
spendenaufkommens ich werde mich dafür
einsetzen dass wir gemeinsam versuchen
spenden in verstärktem maße einzuwerben
auch in der frage der beschaffung einer
partei immobilie werde ich mich mit
einbringen und der die hierfür auch mich
einsetzen und politisch habe ich gesagt
ich bin familienpolitiker und auch hier
werde ich versuchen aus dem
bundesvorstand heraus akzente zu setzen
vielen dank für die frage vielen dank
als nächstes stellt thomas rücke man
eine frage und zwar am blauen mikrofon
bitteschön reichert sie haben ganz
vehement für die einigkeit der partei
gesprochen was wollen sie genau tun um
diese einigkeit durchzusetzen
also ich habe das bereits bei mir im
landesverband denke ich und das können
meine parteifreunde dort bestätigen
getan
ich möchte gespräche führen nach innen
ich möchte insbesondere 1 dass unsere
personalentscheidungen in der partei auf
unseren parteitagen in demokratisch
wohnungen gefasst werden und nicht über
schiedsgerichte das brauchen wir nicht
wir müssen gemeinsam als eine partei in
gesprächen lösungen finden und das ist
möglich weil wir alles vernünftige
menschen sind die im politischen nur ein
ziel verfolgen das eint uns doch alle es
gibt doch gar nicht diesen politischen
unterschied in der partei es sind die
persönlichen animositäten und die müssen
wir im gespräch bei seite drücken darin
sehe ich meine wichtigste aufgabe die
vielen dank die letzte frage stellt
christian lohse am mikro vom roten
mikrofon bitte ja sie sprachen davon
dass hf den jährige hoffen ist sie
selber scheine aber auch was ihre
politische meinung betrifft sehr gierig
zu sein
sie haben verschiedene parteien durch
drei parteien jetzt die vierte partei
was wenn die fünfte partei sein bedanke
mich für diese frage weil es wenig
gelegenheit gibt endlich mal damit
aufzuräumen ich bin tatsächlich damals
in die sozialdemokratie eingetreten ich
komme aus sozialdemokratischer familie
weil ich glaubte ich würde dort noch
menschen wie kurt schumacher finden
soziale patrioten ich habe mich dort um
getan
diese menschen waren nicht da ich bin im
zusammenhang mit der katastrophalen
position der deutschen sozialdemokratie
aus der spd ausgetreten damals schon bei
der schäbigen haltung der spd zur
deutschen wiedervereinigung habe ich
gesagt das ist nicht meine partei
da kann ich nicht dazu da will ich nicht
und ich schäme mich dafür ja ich habe
mehrfach gesagt dieser partei angehört
zu haben und ich bin dann damals bei den
republikanern eingetreten weil ich dort
eine soziale patriotische kraft gesehen
habe diese partei hatte gute ansätze
sie ist dann leider an ihrer eigenen
inneren zerstrittenheit untergegangen
jawohl das war ein problem aber wir
haben es dennoch es ist dennoch so
gewesen dass ich dazu zu dieser
damaligen programmatik stehe bei der fdp
lassen sie mich noch einen satz sagen
ich habe es damals versucht noch einmal
weil ich dachte unter von stahl könnte
es eine national liberale erneuerung
geben dies nicht eingetreten und damit
war das auch für mich vorbei
diese partei zu schätzen
vielen dank dann sind sie mit target
lassen und dann meine damen und herren
darf ich um vorbereitung der abstimmungs
folie bitten es gegangen reichweiten
kandidaten eine frau tritt gegen ein
mann an eine gemäßigte für dieses amt
zurückzukehren zur wahl des
schriftführers
denn diese wahl ist fehlerhaft erfolgt
wenn erfolgreich angefochten der die
wahl des schriftführers kippen
automatisch alle anderen nachfolgenden
wahlen das heißt wir hätten dann einen
halben bundesvorstand verloren wir haben
jetzt relativ wenig zeit investiert die
vorstellungen bleiben bestehen wenn wir
zurückkehren
zur wiederholung der wahl des
schriftführers haben wir den parteitag
wieder gerettet warum der vorschlag für
herrn cruise als schriftführer erfolg
von einem nicht stimmberechtigten
mitglied dieser versammlung nämlich der
bundessprecher erneuten er hat zwar
antragsrecht aber in der satzung ist für
die wahl des vorstandes im absatz sehen
der vorschrift eine sonderregelung
vorschlagsberechtigt sind fünf
stimmberechtigte versammlungsteilnehmer
deswegen habe ich auch gestern gegen
dieses tool prozedere am mikrofon
plädiert und gesagt so was muss vorne am
antrags tisch passieren wo man eben
kontrollieren kann ob die person
jemanden vorschlagen das auch dürfen ob
die dazu befugt sind und nicht hier wo
dann ein bundessprecher sein amt in die
waagschale wirft und natürlich bei so
einem knappen ergebnis ohne weiteres das
ergebnis beeinflusst haben kann womit
eine anfechtung auch erfolg haben könnte
es ist richtig es wurden dann nachher
nach unterstützung gefragt aber damit
war das ganze prozedere bereits
kontaminiert durch den fehler vom herrn
oyten der sich hier etwas angepasst hat
was ihr einfach nicht zusteht denn in
seinem kreisverband wurde er nicht als
delegierter gewählt
und deswegen wenden wir schaden ab von
unserer partei retten wir den parteitag
und kommen wir zurück indem wir den
fehlerhaften wahlgang selbst annullieren
und nicht riskieren dass nachher der
halbe bundesvorstand vor dem
bundesschiedsgericht wieder außen abend
entfernt wird vielen dank
das ist ein antrag die wahl des
schriftführers ist ein hinweis auf einen
formalen fehler denn in der tat haben
halten ist nicht delegierter nicht
gewählter delegierter nahm entscheidet
der versammlungsleiter von fünf
stimmberechtigten delegierten ist das
erforderlich dieses dieser vorschlag
wird bereits seit dem ersten wahlgang
durch aufzeigen dieses stimm bändchens
gegenüber dem wahlleiter der in den
jeweiligen betroffen ist gemacht es ist
richtig dass übrigens stets ein
delegierter auch tatsächlich am mikrofon
stand allerdings muss zu den mitgliedern
des bundesvorstandes ausgeführt werden
dass diese nach satzung jederzeit
rederecht haben und insoweit ist aus
unserer sicht das ganze rechtlich
einzustufen als die aufforderung einen
entsprechenden vorschlag zu machen an
die delegierten
dass das ganze in gewillt gewisser weise
politisch jeder für sich selbst
beurteilen kann ist eine andere frage
aus rechtlicher sicht gibt es da bei uns
keine bedenken nichtsdestotrotz haben
wir einen zu lässigen antrag vom herrn
satz den wir natürlich auch abstimmen
würden nach entsprechender debatte und
die finde ich am blauen mikrofon für den
doktor sex sind sie doch mal so nett und
erklären den unterschied zwischen
rederecht und antragsrecht das würde ich
gerne mal von ihnen erläutert haben das
können sie mal deutlich erläutert ich
finde das hier ist ziemlich schmiererei
und ziemlich mauschelei was hier gerade
neulich bitte erklären sie mir das mein
deutscher kollege blacks ich halte keine
jura vorlesung ich kann ihnen nur sagen
das präsidium sieht den antrag von fünf
stimmberechtigten versammlungsteilnehmer
durch das aufzeigen des bändchens
nichtsdestotrotz gibt es weitere
wortmeldung zum antrag von herrn seitz
ja das ist der ist ebenfalls den flügel
zuzurechnen das ist der der den antrag
eingebracht hat und es geht es darum ob
der parteitag dem antrag das schon
wieder holen die wahl des schriftführers
gegenstimmen enthaltungen dankeschön das
hätten wir gerne elektronisch
das war zu knapp um das einzuschätzen
von hier vorne nochmal zur erklärung
darum ob die wahl des schriftführers
zurückgeführt wird weil ihr seids der
antragsteller ein flügel man formal
einen fehler gesehen haben will in der
in dem prozedere der wahl zum
schriftführer weil er gesagt hatte
der fernkurs vorgeschlagen hat hat
überhaupt kein vorschlagsrecht weil ja
leuten kein delegierter ist und jetzt
geht es darum ob die wahl wiederholt
wird oder nicht
die wahl erfolgt jetzt wieder
elektronisch
das ergebnis dürfte spannend sein aber
mit sicherheit das kann ich ihnen jetzt
schon voraussagen wird es ähnlich knapp
ausgehen wie die eigentliche wahl zum
schriftführer
formal ist es offensichtlich richtig
dass der antrag behandelt wird und die
frage ist ob der parteitag diesem antrag
folgt oder nicht die berühmten 30
sekunden
laufen denn die wahrheit zum
schriftführer ist ja denkbar knapp
gewesen
der herbst hat mit 50,1 stimmen gewonnen
hat gerade mal die einfache mehrheit
genau so erreicht mit der erforderlichen
stimmenzahl und frau beziehen ist ja nur
knapp unterlegen
und dies ist jetzt der versuch diese
wahl zu wiederholen und formale gründe
geschlossen
so ähnlich klang es ist eine knappe
mehrheit der regel 278 08 10
enthaltungen
das heißt die wahl nicht wiederholt
werden ich möchte auch folge mein name
ist eckhard müller landesverband hessen
kreis waren wiesbaden ich möchte auch
folgende regelung in der bundessatzung
zum bundesparteitag reisen § 11 diese
abstimmung wäre gar nicht notwendig
gewesen weil im paragraph und der zweite
reihe steht der bundesparteitag besteht
aus 600 von landesverbänden entsandten
delegierten und zusätzlich bittere 2
diejenigen mitglieder des
bundesvorstandes die nicht gewählte
delegierte sind
ich muss feststellen dass professor
marken heute als er diesen vorschlag
gemacht hat bereits ein gewähltes
bundesvorstandsmitglied war
so dass jemand die bundestag so noch
einmal ganz genau durchgelesen und den
grund gefunden warum es eigentlich
keines antrages bedurfte gesprochen
weitere wortmeldungen gab es nicht und
dann gab es einen entsprechenden antrag
der ist entschieden und ich denke damit
können wir jetzt umgehen und weiter
fortfahren in der sache wir hatten meine
damen und herren die vorstellung zum
ersten beisitzer gehört dort aber das
ist der versuch der gruppe diese
wiederholung herbeizuführen kann man
jetzt als nicht erfolgreich bewerten das
bitte letztmalig draußen noch die
möglichkeit zum einlass gewähren so
jetzt geht es um die wahl um die einzel
wahl des ersten beisitzers zwei personen
stehen zur wahl frau silvia immer noch
mal zur erinnerung die europaabgeordnete
und martin reichert gehört dem
derzeitigen bundestag vorschlagen damit
seine kandidatur rede dass er mitglied
in verschiedenen parteien gewesen ist
unter anderem bei den jusos bei den
republikanern und bei der fdp
wikipedia beschreibt sein vater immer
noch als spd-mitglied anhängig so wie
immer sagt dass sie vorher nie in einer
anderen partei gewesen ist sie ist in
bayreuth geboren
53 jahre und gehört dem kreisverband
bayreuth auch nach wie vor an die
abstimmung dieser beiden kandidaten
läuft man kann ebenfalls sagen dass
diese wahl eine strömungs wahl sein so
interpretiert werden könnte weil martin
reichert eben auch zu der flügelmann
gruppe gehört
er wurde noch als ergänzung gewählt als
vorsitzender von sachsen anhalt als
nachfolger von andré 2018 so das
wahlverfahren läuft ich denke mal dass
die mehrzahl der unter stimme schon
abgegeben wurden
sie hören im radio das ergebnis dürfte
jetzt eingeblendet werden uns voll immer
ebenfalls hat die erforderliche mehrheit
deutlich übertroffen 285 einfach mehr
als 340
damit hat sie die wahl zum ersten
beisitzer gewonnen hat die erforderliche
einfache mehrheit erreicht und ich frage
sie nimmt sie die wahl an
frau doktor limmer nimmt die wahl an
bildern und herzlichen glückwunsch meine
damen und herren ich komme sie dann zur
zweiten zu wählenden beisitzer
positionen hierfür bitte ich um ihre
vorschläge am roten mikrofon bitteschön
ja ich schlage herrn gottschalk von
gottschalk
am tag war bisher einer der
stellvertreter im vorherigen
bundesvorstand andreas kalbitz gehört
ausgewiesen was uns flügel der partei
gibt es weitere forscher ist ebenfalls
ist er im bundesvorstand der partei
gewesen und zwar ebenfalls als beisitzer
das darf ich noch ergänzen andreas
kalbitz war bisher ebenfalls beisitzer
im bundesvorstand der partei
die kann ich jetzt nicht mehr erkennen
dann bitte ich mir wird zustimmung die
kandidatenliste damit zu schließen wäre
dem zustimmt blaue stimmkarte bitte
vielen dank gegenstimmen
danke enthaltungen vielen dank stelle
ich fest ist die kandidaten liste
geschlossen ich frage herr gottschalk
stehen sie zur wahl bereit
ja ich frage herrn kalbitz stehen sie
zur wahl bereit
ja und ich frage herr vogler stehen sie
zur wahl bereits jetzt nicht dann haben
wir zwei neue kandidaten die herren
gottschald und kalbitz und die
vorstellungs reihenfolge wird ausgelost
ja das ist jetzt mehr oder weniger die
dritte die man so interpretieren kann
strömungs politische wahl weil
gottschalk eben 14 30 den flügel gezählt
werden kann und andreas kalbitz ja immer
ein protagonist ein herausgehobener
protagonist des flügels ist da ist
kalbitz auch zunächst an sie die pflicht
fragen enthielt ein aktuelles
polizeiliches führungszeugnis eintragung
beschuldigung jetzt nein und erklären
sie uns bitte ihre früheren
parteizugehörigkeit csu und einem jahr
republikaner konnte vielen dank dann
fünf minuten zeit für die vorstellung
sie dürfen beginnt ja vielen dank ich
nutze die gelegenheit mich auch
persönlich noch mal vorzustellen ist ja
doch einige neue delegierte da mein name
ist andreas kalbitz ich bin 47 jahre alt
seit 25 jahren verheiratet drei kinder
22 20 18
ich bin fraktions und landesvorsitzender
in brandenburg und hatte schon die ehre
den bundesvorstand zwei jahre
anzugehören
ich habe natürlich auch ein leben vor
der politik gehabt wir machen das alle
noch nicht so lange da war ich zwölf
jahre falsche mega also bei der
bundeswehr und bin medienkaufmann
zurückblickend auf das was der
bundesvorstand getan hat oder das was
ich da getan habe wir haben uns ja mit
dem bundesvorstand in
geschäftsverteilungsplan gegeben
da kann man sagen das ist normal das hat
es vorher nicht gegeben das war schwach
der strukturelle neuerungen
da war mein zuständigkeitsbereich ganz
klar die junge alternative
das war eine große herausforderung und
kann man auch dann als teil einer
leistungsbilanz sehen weil wir mit
unserer j turbulente zeiten hatten
innerhalb der letzten zwei jahre und es
tatsächlich darum ging ob man die orte
jetzt abgeliefert oder nicht das war
eine tendenz gegen die ich ganz klar an
gekämpft habe warum wir können uns als
größte oppositionspartei deutschland
nicht von unserer jugendorganisation
lösen das geht natürlich nicht
und ich freue mich dass in der
zusammenarbeit mit toyota wo es um die
verfehlungen einzelner gingen wir
geschafft haben nicht nur die usa zu
erhalten sondern gut aufzustellen und
ich glaube dass wir in zukunft noch
wichtiger ist weil wir eine partei sind
die zukunft als volkspartei und wir
merken das ja auch an den zahlen das
muss man ganz klar sagen wir haben im
osten ja ich gestehe unter schmerzen
nach den grünen
den höchsten anteil an jungen
erstwählern und auch im westen sieht es
nicht schlecht aus wenn wir uns mal die
shell jugendstudie anschauen
die masse der jungen menschen hat immer
noch einen konservativen lebensentwurf
die wollen wir abholen als neue
bürgerliche kraft und deshalb gilt mein
bestreben auch für den zukünftigen
bundesvorstand ganz klar jugendarbeit zu
stärken die jugendarbeit voran zu
bringen und uns da noch stärker
aufzustellen
in vielen bereichen der wahlkampf und
andere dinge gar nicht möglich ohne die
j dafür bedanke ich mich auch nochmal
welche aufgaben liegen vor uns für
diesen bundesvorstand in den letzten
zwei jahren hatten wir haben wir die
bundestagswahlen vorbereitet begleitet
strukturellen städten unglaubliche
arbeit dahinter auch die europawahlen
und es hört natürlich jetzt nicht auf
und das ist auch das was der
bundesvorstand zu leisten hat hier geht
es nicht um sonntagsreden um politische
deklarationen das ist knallharte
struktur arbeit und wir müssen
vorbereitet sein
wir reden über die wahlen im westen wir
werden wenn wir volkspartei werden
wollen können die ergebnisse im osten
auf die ich sehr stolz bin so schön sein
wie sie wollen aber wir brauchen den
zuwachs im westen um auf volkspartei auf
bundesebene breit aufgestellt zu sein
wir reden von den jahren 20 21 wir reden
von den kommunalwahlen in nrw wo es
strategisch schon mit einem auge drauf
chile da müssen wir uns verwurzeln um
weiter verfestigt zu werden weil eines
ist klar wir wollen dieselbe nachricht
in den westen senden wie sie im osten
angekommen ist ja fd ist gekommen um zu
bleiben und das muss unser ziel sein
auch in westdeutschland
darum wird stratege stehen
darum wird stratege stehen und wir haben
ja noch das damoklesschwert der
neuwahlen
wer die entwicklung bei der spd ist
verfolgt hat es ist ja fast egal wer da
im vorstand oder als vorsitzende werde
als totengräber das licht ausmacht bei
diese champagner sozialisten darum geht
es gar nicht aber das kann bedeuten dass
für neuwahlen bekommen und die meisten
wissen man ist gerade raus aus dem
wahlkampf dann geht das wieder los auch
da müssen wir uns strukturell
vorbereiten du wirst die strukturen
schaffen um das auch auffangen zu können
als ist ein hartes stück arbeit das vor
dem neuen bundesvorstand liegt was muss
ich ganz klar selbstkritisch auch
betrachten wo gibt's noch
verbesserungsbedarf dass es
kampagnenfähigkeit da haben wir nicht
immer schnell genug reagiert ich
erinnern mal an die vs kampagne
das hat monate gedauert bis wir soweit
waren da ist also deutlicher
verbesserungsbedarf
natürlich gilt auch für bundesvorstand
das was schon besser war
was auch für die partei als solche wir
müssen den in beschäftigungsanteil
reduzieren werden wir einen großen teil
der kraft die wir nach innen verwenden
nach außen verwenden würden dann werden
wir noch stärker und daran müssen wir
arbeiten in jeder hinsicht und zwar
gemeinsam
weil 1 muss aber klar sein wie prozent
wir haben als afd sind kein leistungs
bonus die sind vertrauensvorschuss der
menschen da draußen und ich habe mir
vorgenommen dazu beizutragen dieses
vertrauen zu erfüllen als letzte chance
die wir vielleicht in diesem land haben
und deshalb bitte ich sie und euch um
euer vertrauen filtern dankeschön er
soweit andreas kalbitz der geborene
münchner und war mal fallschirmjäger und
ist seit 1994 mit einer britin
verheiratet
es beginnt lisa lehmann sondern nun die
fragen an herrn kalbitz aus der
deligierten schafft die zweite frage
kommt von sebastian marx und die dritte
von anna leisten frauen leben am roten
micro bitteschön jahr wird sie sagen
immer sie möchten die junge attraktive
unterstützende im bundesvorstand sind
doch bekannt dafür dass sie das auch
schon den letzten zwei jahren gemacht
haben aber wie soll das in zukunft in
den nächsten zwei jahren aussehen und
wieso fühlen sich so wichtig gerade den
nachwuchs fördern ja vielen dank das
habe ich also ich würde mich jetzt
wieder holen mit dem was sie schon
gesagt habe und was ist dabei auch geht
auch wenn klaus voormann jetzt leicht
das gesicht verziehen wird wir werden
geld in die hand nehmen müssen
das ist ganz klar von nichts kommt
nichts der plot baumann freut sich jetzt
schon und da müssen wir schauen dass wir
enger zusammenarbeiten das uns enger
verzahnen
das klappt in einigen bundesländern
schon ganz gut da ist noch luft nach
oben und den rest möchte ich nicht
wiederholen was ich vorhin schon gesagt
danke schön dann am blauen mikrofon herr
marx die adresse bist ja opfer einer
oder ziel einer schmutz und
verleumdungskampagne geworden im rahmen
des wahlkampfes
aber offensichtlich ist es an ihm
abgeprallt kannst du erklären wie das
funktioniert
es geht ja um zwei dinge es geht darum
dass natürlich medial versucht wird
narrativ zu setzen da geht es ja darum
dass gedreht wird und dinge vermengt
werden ich freue mich auch übrigens dass
ich jetzt vor kurzer zeit eine
einstweilige verfügung gegen den swr
durchgebracht habe man irgendwann muss
man da auch mal grenzen zu ziehen und
wie geht man damit um
das ist ja immer eine sehr persönliche
sache betrifft auch die familie
wie geht man damit um man geht damit um
wenn man dem grundsatz folgt was scherz
die deutsche eiche wenn sich die säue
dran reiben und die letzte frage von
frau leisten
sie waren spitzenkandidat in brandenburg
zur landtagswahl
was hat ihrer meinung nach den wahlkampf
so besonders gemacht
das ist eine frage die man jetzt nicht
in einer minute beantwortet ich glaube
was ich sehr genossen
wahlkämpfe sind gemeinschaftswerk und es
ist ja wenn manche glauben im westen wie
im osten
wir kriegen das geschenkt das ist falsch
da muss man auch um jede stimme kämpfen
und dieses gemeinschaftswerk dass bürger
bisher angesprochen hat das war das wo
allen einsatz gebracht haben und ja am
schluss war auch die luft raus war
keiner mehr richtig konnte aber bis
dahin haben alle alles gegeben und wenn
wir so weit als bundes partei sind dann
bin ich völlig zuversichtlich wir
versenken die spd wir schieben die cdu
in diese junior koalitionspartner
situation im kleinsten kleinster größe
und nehmen dann übernehmen verantwortung
für dieses land
vielen dank das waren die drei frage
vielen dank galt es für die vorstellung
und dann bitte ich den zweiten bewerber
herr ngos anfragen die zumeist von der
jungen alternativen liste gekommen waren
das ist die nachwuchsorganisation der
afd
und jetzt kommt der zweite kandidat für
den posten des beisitzers cargo zeit
gebürtig aus hamburg auch bei ihnen
beginnen wir mit den pflicht fragen
enthielt er ein aktuelles polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragung ist er täte
keine und erklärt sich bitte zur
früheren parteizugehörigkeit von 1982
bis 1990 in der spd
danke schön dann auch für sie fünf
minuten zeit für die vorstellung bitte
sehr
dankeschön sehr geehrte damen und herren
vor zwei jahren stand ich nicht weit von
hier auch auf der bühne
hannover sie werden sich vielleicht
erinnern damals wurden wir wie heute von
linksradikalen angegriffen und zunächst
an dieser stelle möchte ich mich daher
bei der polizei bedanken für alle
sozialen fehlleistung für jeden der
demokratischen parteien ihre knochen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes hier inhalt
meine damen und herren
was mir geblieben ist die erkenntnis ein
kaputtes handgelenk behalten zu haben
und einer kaputt eines kaputten rechts
eines kaputten rechtsstaat ist denn das
verfahren wurde wegen mangelnden
öffentlichen interesses eingestellt
meine damen und herren die afg es in
diesem land freiwild geworden das ist x
factor aber es ist ja auch heute der
erste advent und damit geht auch das
politische jahr 20 19 zu ende zu einem
anlass guter besinnlichkeit fahren hier
aber auch parteipolitischer es ist
nämlich die grundsatzfrage hier heute zu
stellen
wie steht es um deutschland meine damen
und herren deutschland ist das einzige
land auf der welt in dem man dem volk
und auch den medien dort draus mache ich
den vorwurf 20 jahre lang versprichst
den soli abzuschaffen und am ende des
tages ihnen nicht abschafft und es dann
als soziale wohltat verkaufen kann meine
damen und herren
deutschland ist das einzige land auf der
welt das terroristen des islamischen
staates mit offener hand wieder
zurücknimmt meine damen und herren und
deutschland deutschland ist das einzige
land auf der welt das sich zwar als
demokratie bezeichnet bei dabei die
größte oppositionspartei deutschlands
nämlich die afd
angst um leib und leben haben muss die
zahlen des dritten quartals sprechen da
für sich
im schnitt werden alle fünf tage unsere
parteibüros angegriffen und jeden tag
wird durchschnittlich 1 afd mitglied
opfer einer politisch motivierten
gewalttat und wien haben wir eigentlich
diesen sonderweg zu verdanken
nur der antifa in der lieben damen und
herren nur den verbündeten der medien da
drüben meine damen und herren
nein nein liebe freunde die lügen der
wahnsinn und die verfolgung der einzigen
echten oppositionsparteien diesem lande
ist regierungsprogrammen geworden
bei jedem cent dem einem deutschen
handwerksmeister oder einer deutschen
krankenschwester aus dem portmonee
gezogen wird lässt schulden olaf in
berlin die korken sein meine damen und
herren bei jedem die sg gera steht unser
innenminister imitator seehofer schmiere
und applaudiert meine damen und herren
und bei jedem anti fanden der zuschlägt
sitzt frau merkel mit ihrer politik
am steuer des fluchtautos liebe freunde
das ist kein schlechter film über den
umgang mit der opposition in china nein
das ist gelebte politische leitkultur
mittlerweile in deutschland geworden
staatlich finanziert
mein name ist kein gottschalk ich bin 53
jahre alte bankkaufmann und ihr
bundestagsabgeordneter in den letzten
zwei jahren durfte ich in unserer partei
hat stellvertretender bundesvorsitzender
zu diensten sein
wer in dieser dienstzeit habe ich dafür
gestritten dass unsere partei
schlagkräftiger und professioneller wird
und ich habe das nicht so mittmann
juristischen kenntnissen getan wie sie
es ja in magdeburg und riesa sehen
konnten ich habe die europawahl
vorbereitet
ich habe dort unserer partei einen hohen
500.000 euro starken betrag eingespart
weil es meine idee war dass er endlich
professionell werden und auf vier tage
gehen so konnten wir ein wochenende
einsparen
[Applaus]
und liebe freunde heute steht die afg
nach einer jüngsten umfrage
niedersachsen bei fast 12 prozent
doppelt so viel wie bei der landtagswahl
das liegt sicherlich auch an der guten
arbeit liegt aber auch daran dass ich
als notvorstand die mum hatte dieses
chaos dort zu beenden was dort vorhanden
war
und die die hier muss sagen das sind die
meistens die das schicksal der
republikaner betragen und selbst nicht
in der lage sind verordnung in der
partei zu sorgen und die geschichte der
republikaner zu kennen denn ab und zu
muss man auch mal nein sagen können
liebe freunde dann kann man nämlich auch
diese parteien
meine damen und herren ich stehe für
eine patriotische und professionelle ft
und für weiterhin eine erfolgreiche afd
eine demokratische afd in der mitglieder
in ost und west das sagen haben und
nicht irgendwelche parteipolitischen
gruppierung liebe freunde kommen sie zum
schluss
liebe freunde nur so bleibt die fdp die
partei die wir alle lieben auf die wir
stolz sein können
deshalb bitte ich um ihre stimme für den
erfolg dafür dass ja auch ein
wirtschaftliches gesicht haben wie sie
sehen das werde ich bitten und da bin
ich schon mal vertrauen dankeschön
willen dann gibt es gibt fragen die
werden wir auch eine sehr pointierte
kandidaten rede des finanzpolitischen
sprechers des tages der fdp gottschalk
ich trinke sogar auf sein glas sei alles
gut hier
so geht das auch
so jetzt kommen die frauen erste hatte
mehrmals zu applaus genötigt oder bzw
sie haben immer ab notiert die
delegierten und die dritte frage mike
juli zermatt ist am blauen mikrofon
bitte sehr
herr gottschalk unser rentensystem
kollabiert voraussichtlich im jahr 2025
welche ideen haben sie weg alternativen
anbieter tätigen sie welche gedanken
jähnigen dazu durch den kopf da geht man
zum beispiel durch den kopf dass wir
nicht einfach planlos und seine eu
haushalt auf 45 milliarden euro in 20 24
also von jetzt nahezu verdoppeln dieses
geld kann gerne hier bleiben dazu bleibt
mir und geht mir im kopf liebe kollegen
in europa in europa die
steuerhinterziehung und steuervermeidung
auf eu-ebene das sind ganz stolz 825
milliarden euro jedes jahr also ein tage
zwei saldo zu verhindert damit können
durch geld die herzigen 100 milliarden
und vielleicht auch in 20 jahren 20
milliarden entsprechend dort hinein zu
packen was wir jetzt schon müssen
ich bin nämlich zu diesem gesetzlichen
rentensystem auch da sehen sie dass ich
überhaupt irgendwo für alle gaben das
gesetzliche rentensystem muss bleiben
und von dieser rente müssen die menschen
hier in deutschland auch leben können
und zwar menschenwürdig und besser als
jeder der in hartz4 ist oder der hier
gerade zufällig über die grenze
gestolpert ist liebe freunde
die zweite frage kommt von michael
nützel abermals klaus mit hallo herr
gottschalk lee baca du bist doch in
seiner funktion einen bestimmten ressort
zugeteilt gewesen den letzten periode
wie sie denn da hat eine perspektive für
die nächste periode auswahl wird ich
wähle und warum warst du eigentlich geht
dabei und es in der gesundheit
also meine perspektive sieht so aus ich
hatte vor allen dingen das rechtssystem
zu betreuen
ich hatte in den ersten fünf monaten den
notvorstand zu machen das heißt mädchen
für alles die perspektive wird sein dass
wir uns im saarland kümmern müssen das
ist auch völlig klar dass klang ja schon
an die perspektive wird sein dass wir
egal ob vorgezogen oder nicht eine
bundestagswahl zu organisieren haben dem
will ich mich wieder stellen in den
parteitagen und professionell als
versammlungsleitung die perspektive muss
sein unsere schiedsgerichtsbarkeit
weiter zu stärken
die perspektive muss sein ja die jorker
voranzubringen aber auch immer kritisch
zu gucken nämlich das gehört auch dazu
kein laisser-faire einfelder see liebe
freunde das gehört einfach dazu und
und ich hatte das ressort content haben
wir ja viele strukturreform auch angel
anbelangt das sind einmal die tageszeit
räume ist auch dass andere sich jetzt
mit drum kümmern können weil man eben
nicht immer die zeit hat und eine
perspektive wird auf jeden fall sein
dass unsere partei endlich auch als
soziale partei als soziale partei der
gerechtigkeit wahrgenommen wird und auch
als kompetenz in steuerfragen
das kam nicht zu kurz in unserer partei
leider die zeit ist um
die dritte frage stellt juli zum roten
jacke gottschalk ich würde sagen oder
sehe das genauso wie sie eine
essentielle aufgabe des bundesvorstandes
ist eine einheitliche demonstration der
partei nach außen und nun meine frage
wie kommen sie dann dazu als delegierter
des bundesvorstandes auf dem letzten
landesparteitag 60 prozent der dortigen
parteifreunde als hampel gang zu
bezeichnen denn ich fand das eine
bodenlose frechheit muss nicht
realisieren
danke
zwar meint dazu wenn man sich einem
konstruktiven dialog verweigert wenn man
tatsächlich und am ende des tages hinter
ja dann zu einem konstruktiven dialog
gekommen
ganz einfach dem anderen nicht zu ich
glaube zur debattenkultur und zu einem
miteinander wie sie es einfordern gehört
dass man einander zuhört und dann auch
die kritikpunkte aufnimmt und zu diesem
zeitpunkt den sie beschreiben sollte
gerade etwas verlesen werden und dann
verließen tatsächlich einige leute den
raum liebe freunde ja und da bin ich
tatsächlich einer der klare worte findet
und dem landesverband niedersachsen die
zahlen sprechen für sich hat es geholfen
und er auch noch mal herzlichen
glückwunsch an die landes- fraktion und
an den toll arbeiten den landesvorstand
der nämlich alle mitten im dorf der
macht nämlich genau das was wir alle
verlangen und deswegen stelle ich mich
dann auch schützen davor wenn ein
funktionierender landesverband ja ein
landesverband aus dem chaos rausgeholt
hat dann in der art und weise mit
desinteresse und mit rausgehen bestraft
das kriegt hier sehen wir mit recht auch
bei cdu csu im bundestag
das kritisiere ich auch in der eigenen
partei und das gehört dazu dankeschön
wirtschaft für die vorstellung und meine
damen und herren dann kommen wir zum
nächsten wahlgang
ich finde da waren die drei fragen von
den delegierten an kein gottschalk und
jetzt geht es in der wahl um den zweiten
beisitzer in der tat auch wieder darum
wie sich der parteitag entscheidet und
auch hier für diese dritte wahl die wir
ihnen tragen wo sage ich es wird für
beide allerdings wirklich sehr sehr
spannend weil beides eben ausgewiesene
kandidaten für ihre jeweiligen
strömungen innerhalb der partei sind
besonders andreas kalbitz ist ja
regelmäßig auch bei dem kyffhäuser
treffen des flügels dass jedes jahr
einmal
etwa stattfindet dabei aber wir warten
die entscheidung jetzt einfach ab
ungefähr 30 sekunden dauert's noch und
dann haben wir das ergebnis
ich denke mal bei der haben für ihre
strömungen positionierte reden gehalten
und der parteitag wird dann entscheiden
welchen der beiden kandidaten er die
stimme gibt
warten wir es einfach mal ab wir haben
noch 15 sekunden
bitte geben sie ihre stimme ab und wir
schließen meine damen und herren bei 32
und jetzt kommt das ergebnis geschlossen
das ergebnis erforderliche mehrheit
das klingt nach einer erneuten nein
stimmten 41 delegierte und 6 haben sich
enthalten
wir machen nach bekannte art und weise
eine stichwahl vorher bitte die tür auf
bitte eintreten
wer keiner mehr will tür wieder zu
dann ist die tür wieder zu wunderbar die
abstimmungs folie wieder einblenden
sie finden erneute herrn gottschalk auf
der eins herrn kallwitz auf der 2
mit der nummer drei die einstimmung auf
der vier die enthaltung die abstimmungs
eröffnet ja nochmal die stichwahl zum
zweiten beisitzer insgesamt werden ja
vier beisitzer gewählt dann dürfte der
gesamte bundesvorstand der neu gewählte
bundesvorstand dann auf dem podium platz
nehmen um danach die reden der neuen
bundessprecher zu hören
das sind ja jörg merten der gestern
wieder gewählt wurde mit knapp 70
prozent und kino copala der neugewählte
bundessprecher aus dem neuen
bundesländern
danach wird es noch eine letzte wahl
geben nämlich die des ehrenvorsitzenden
nicht erwähnte ist bereits kann es an
dieser stelle aber noch mal hervorheben
weil sicherlich diese wahl am
einfachsten und am unproblematischen
ablaufen wird denn das ist ein neu
geschaffenes amt ein ehrenamt das einen
einzigen kandidaten hat und zwar
alexander gauland kommt das 2 diesmal
hat der flügelmann
die wahl gewonnen eine stimme über dem
meer heißt 91 mit nein votierten 39 und
drei enthaltungen
ich darf jetzt stellen heck ein blitz
hat die erforderliche einfache mehrheit
erreicht und es damit zum beisitzer im
bundesvorstand gewählt
ich frage hand kallwitz nehmen sie diese
wahl an
gallwitz kalbitz hallo nehmen ja in
einem damen ja da stecken auch zum
gratulieren bereit und die anderen
partei mitglieder die andreas cordes
jetzt zu dieser wahl gratulieren der
feier im vorherigen bundesland
bundesvorstand auf vertreten und ist
jetzt wieder zweiter beisitzer alt
geworden
das ist nach der dritten wahl neben
johannes kues und sylvia glimmer
sozusagen die erste flügel wahl die mit
einem jungen protagonisten dieser ropac
junge volk bestritten bitte zum einsatz
kommt so jetzt geht in die wahlen des
dritten beisitzers von insgesamt vier
steht bisher ein name auf der liste
dürfen haug weitere vorschläge
klaus micro nochmal ich schlage vor
auch ein gültiger vorschlag am roten
mikrofon hat sich jemand bereit gemacht
ich schlage jörg schock vor gültiger
vorschlag das mikrofon bitte sehr
joachim schneider landesvorstand
schleswig holstein
joachim schneider auch gültig als
vorschlag des micro schlag an mathias
kukla aus nürnberg vor gibt es
inzwischen fünf kandidaten stark vor und
den vorschlag für den ball des oval des
dritten beisitzers auch gerichtlich als
wieder herr gottschalk mit kann
gottschalk gibt es weitere vorschläge
bisher vorgeschlagenen jochen hauke
later bilde jörg schock joachim
schneider matthias vogler und kalk
gottschalk am roten nico ich möchte die
niedersächsischen bundestagsabgeordneten
jens geßner vorschlagen jens kästner
auch okay
gültiger vorschlag gibt es jetzt noch
weitere vorschläge für den dritten zu
wählenden beisitzer die kann ich nicht
mehr erkennen dann bitte ich um ihre
zustimmung die kandidatenliste damit zu
schließen wir den zustimmt die blaue
stimmkarte bitte danke schön wärs gegen
die schließung der kandidatenliste
enthaltungen stelle ich fest dass die
kandidatenliste geschlossen
ich frage jochen hauke stehen sie zur
verfügung
unser er steht bereit
jeder pilger stehen sie zur verfügung
[Musik]
kann ich nicht sagen die konkurrenz
ob die vorschläge auch realisiert werden
können das heißt ob die namen der
delegierten optimierten auch bereit
stehen
joachim schneider steht auch bereit
matthias vogler bei der auswahl doch
niemand ich doch nicht danke herr
gottschalk große nein hab ich gehört
und herr jens kestler noch nicht
dann stehen zur wahl jetzt jochen haug
leider bilder jörg schock und joachim
schneider die haben sich alle noch nicht
vorgestellt die reihenfolge losen wir
aus zur wahl stehen drei männer eine
frau die alle er aus der zweiten und
dritten reihe der prominenz in der afg
kommen anders als wenn der vorhang
vorangegangenen wahl zwischen gottschalk
und andreas kalbitz kam es ja zu einer
wahl die in zwei wahlgängen entschieden
wurde
als er sie mal durch auch als strömungs
wahl bewerten kann
als zweites joachim schneider
als drittes jochen hauke
und demzufolge als viertes leila pilger
und zuerst kommt herr schock auf die
bühne
von dem wir jetzt gerade ein bisschen
was gelesen haben und er gehört er dem
flügel gruppierung der flügel
gruppierung an
so wanderten ich darf zunächst bevor wir
zu dieser kandidatenvorstellung kommen
in gewohnter weise bitten die größere
traube dort links vor dem gästeblock
aufzulösen
das gebietet die fairness gegenüber
jedem bewerber meine damen und herren
dort links am gästeblock bitte nehmen
sie ihre delegierten plätze wieder ein
oder aber gehen sie raus wenn sie sich
unterhalten wollen das stört sie sehen
natürlich dass die vorangegangene wahl
noch nachwirkt und logischerweise da vor
allen dingen wie journalisten natürlich
interessiert sind um dort als roman- und
bewertungen seine damen und herren
nochmals der deutliche aufrufe an die
herrschaften im bereich der gästetribüne
aber allerdings im delegierten bereich
dort vor der gästetribüne bitte die
gespräche nach draußen verlegen oder
sich hinsetzen den delegierten bereich
so geht es nicht das ist entschieden zu
laut
vielen dank der schock ist hier vorne
angekommen ist die pflicht fragen würde
ein aktuelles polizeiliches
führungszeugnis eintragungen enthalten
hatte noch nie eintragungen und wird
auch nie welche bekommen
dankeschön und erklären sie sich bitte
zu früheren parteizugehörigkeit die afg
es meine erste politische heimat und
meine heimat wechsel ich nicht sagt
dankeschön dann haben sie jetzt fünf
minuten zeit sich vorzustellen dass er
einen guten tag liebe delegierte mein
name ist jörg schock ich bin 43 jahre
alt und mitglied der afg seit 2000 16
ich bin landes delegierter in hessen und
ersatzdelegierte für den bundeskonvent
als buchautor habe ich 2016 angefangen
ein buch zu schreiben wie ich mir die
optimale politik in deutschland
vorstellen
um zu wissen worum sich die politik
überhaupt kümmert habe ich mich mit
allen parteiprogrammen aller namhaften
parteien auseinander gesetzt
in dem zuge bin ich auch an den
leitantrag zum grundsatzprogramm der afg
geraten
vorher habe ich in meinem buch konzept
in meinem entwurf schon grundsätzlich
ist niedergeschrieben
zu meiner verwunderung meine
niederschrift parteien teilen wortgetreu
identisch zu dem was in dem leitantrag
zum grundsatzprogramm von bereits nieder
geschrieben war
so kam ich im mai 2016 in die idee ich
bin also in die afg eingetreten weil ich
von der programmatik voll und ganz
überzeugt bin
so meine damen und herren das verfahren
wird jetzt für die wahlen bis zum ende
des bundesvorstands bis zum ende der
bundesforschungs war noch eine geraume
zeit weitergeführt das gibt uns
gelegenheit so alexander keller ans set
zu gehen um eine analyse des
bundesparteitages zu erfahren
ja und zu dieser analyse sind maria
fiedler vom berliner tagesspiegel und
isabell borucki politikwissenschaftlerin
von der universität duisburg-essen
borucki man sich die wahlen jetzt an sie
die gäste gelaufen sind zu den beiden
vorsitzenden zu den stellvertretern
jetzt auch die beisitzer wahl was sagt
das über die stimmung in der partei aus
und auch über das ja das meinungsbild
oder die überzeugung die hier auf dem
parteitag zum ausdruck kommen sehr
deutlich gesehen meines erachtens nach
dass die partei gemäßigter geworden ist
oder sich den anschein gibt gemäßigter
zu sein
sie positioniert sich damit strategische
auf dem wählermarkt logischerweise
öffnet sich für neue wähler märkte
respektive für konservative unionswähler
und ich frage mich allerdings ob es
tatsächlich der fall ist dass diese
partei jetzt wirklich gemäßigter ist
denn die rechtsradikalen gruppen sind
natürlich weiterhin existent in dieser
partei und auch in ihren augen
unterstützer organisationen
nun scheint man die hier in der partei
auch auf ausgewogenheit zwischen den
verschiedenen flügel dem flügel den eher
gemäßigten zu setzen das hat man gerade
bei der wahl gesehen
andreas kalbitz hat sich gegen kai
gottschalk durchgesetzt obwohl die eine
gute vorstellung hier hatte ist das auch
wichtig für die partei dass hier alle
flügel nach wie vor integriert werden
ja darauf legt man in der parteien schon
großen wert dass man integration auch
der der strömungen schafft das ist ja
auch was was sich der neue
parteivorsitzende tino europa so ein
bisschen auf die fahnen geschrieben hat
aber gleichzeitig sieht man eben auch
bei so knappen ball ausgängen das zwar
auf ausgleich geachtet wird aber dass
trotzdem die partei auch gespalten ist
zwischen denen die sich doch eher als
gemäßigter sehen und den radikalen
hier auf dem parteitag noch auf
erstaunliche stimme ergebnisse zum teil
erzielt haben sind hier auf dem
parteitag schon heiratsanträge abgegeben
worden richtung cdu
da möchte man mit langfristig ein
bündnis eingehen andererseits gibt es ja
auch in der partei einige das hat man
auch bei der rede von alexander gauland
gestern gesehen die bei diesem vorschlag
von ihm nicht geklatscht haben wollen
also sozusagen eigentlich für sich
bleiben wie wird sich die entwicklung
der partei da absehbar weitergehen ja
das ist jetzt schwierig vorherzusagen
ehrlich gesagt aber ich kann mir
vorstellen dass es jetzt mit diesem
vorsitzenden team tatsächlich gelingen
könnte die partei hinter sich zu
versammeln wenngleich natürlich immer
noch schwierig ist die partei sagte ja
selber jetzt auch hier auf dem parteitag
das ist immer noch eingehender hoffen
dass wir haben jetzt auch bei den gerade
bei der schriftführer war und diversen
anderen wahlgängen gesehen das ist ganz
schnell andere das ganz schnell stimmung
aufkommen können und die kandidaten
nicht mehr unterstützt werden bzw wie
viele eben gerade auch sagte es sehr
sehr knappe wahlergebnis einfach waren
was für mich auch eben diese
gespaltenheit der partei sehr sehr
deutlich offen legt also insofern ist
noch immer alles drin in diesem spiel
ist es auch eine art umarmungsstrategie
gegenüber der union die da jetzt gerade
versucht wird jetzt mehrfach ja auch
erneuten hat das ja ganz klar gesagt wir
müssen bündnisfähig sein das hört man
hier sehr oft ist dass die die strategie
die man jetzt eigentlich eine eher
umarmungsstrategie hier hatte ja sogar
jemand gesagt die werden noch einmal
froh sein in der union wenn ihr als
juniorpartner akzeptieren es hat mir
auch ein leeres gesagt hat und der als
kalbitz und hat dann so gemacht aber als
so kleiner juniorpartner
was wird er beabsichtigt also die
strategie ist eigentlich ganz klar ist
der cdu so schwer wie möglich zu machen
ihrer basis zu erklären warum man nicht
mit der fdp koalition in erwägung zieht
also die fdp versucht sich als
bürgerlich zu verkaufen um quasi auch
ein bürgerliches bündnis in aussicht zu
stellen was ist ja so de facto nicht
sein kann weil die auf die ist keine
bürgerliche partei aber man will sich
jetzt nach diesem parteitag auch so
darstellen
weil man eben an die cdu-basis
appellieren wir von der mann ausgeht
dass sie eben auch manchmal sagt es gibt
positionen bei der afg die finden wir
auch gut und da ist eben der cdu-führung
so sehr schwer zu machen das ist das
kalkül gespaltenheit gesprochen gerade
auch durch die abstimmungsergebnisse
könnte es sein selbst wenn ich hier sehr
gemäßigte töne zu hören waren dass ich
vielleicht doch noch mal der radikalere
flügel in der kfd durch sitzt je nachdem
wie sich auch die innenpolitische
entwicklung in deutschland zeigt die
frage ist es was wir unter durchsetzen
verstehen also jetzt hier bei den wahlen
zum bundesvorstand hat sich natürlich
ich meine für die zukunftssichere partei
teil durchgesetzt aber für die zukunft
könnte es tatsächlich sein dass der der
flügel noch mehr macht bekommt es ist ja
je nachdem welche studie man anschaut
zwischen 40 und 60 prozent die rede
der mitglieder die sympathien gegenüber
diesem parteitag ja einfach haben und
hier auch potenzielle innerparteiliche
unterstützer wären also insofern ist ein
großes innerparteiliches potenzial was
auch immer dazu führen kann dass das
wieder nach oben bringen so zu sagen und
die gemäßigteren kandidaten in
bedrängnis bringt letztlich was meinen
sie ist der flügel da schon eher muss er
jetzt zurück stecken oder steckt noch
mehr potenzial drin was dann die partei
wieder radikalisieren könnte wir haben
uns gesehen einige flügel kandidaten
sind nicht durchgekommen
gleichzeitig muss man ja sagen dass auch
der neue parteivorsitzende tino kubala
zwar kein flügelmann ist aber zumindest
ja gut mit dem flügel auskommt und er
war ja auch nicht nur der wunschkandidat
von alexander gauland sondern auch der
wunschkandidat des flügels insofern ist
seine wahl
trotzdem auch zum teilen erfolg des
flügels insofern würde ich jetzt auch
nicht sagen dass dieser parteitag für
den flügel komplett schlecht gelaufen
wäre
es geht bei der parteien für die partei
darum alle mitzunehmen nur dann hat man
auch erfolg das war ja auch die
bisherige strategie ich bedanke mich für
das gespräch bei maria fiedler vom
tagesspiegel aus berlin und bei isabel
produkte von der universität
duisburg-essen live zuschauer wir werden
jetzt den kfd parteitag verlassen hier
aus braunschweig denn im phoenix
programm steht der internationale
frühschoppen auf der agenda und danach
dann noch internationaler frühschoppen
nachgefragt moderation heute helge fußt
war ein riesiges reich beherrscht von
einer türkischen dynastie die ihren
ursprung in kleinasien hatte die